welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday life
I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a professor
of neurobiology and Ophthalmology at
Stanford school of medicine today my
guest is Dr ODed rakhavi Dr ODed rakhavi
is a professor of neurobiology at Tel
Aviv University in Israel his laboratory
studies genetic inheritance now
everybody is familiar with genetic
inheritance as the idea that we inherit
genes from our parents and indeed that
is true many people are also probably
now aware of the so-called epigenome
that is ways in which our environment
and experiences can change our genome
and therefore the genes that we inherit
or pass on to our children
what is less known however and what is
discussed today is the evidence that we
can actually pass on traits that relate
to our experiences that's right there is
evidence in worms in flies in mice and
indeed in human beings that memories can
indeed be passed from one generation to
the next and that turns out to be just
the tip of the iceberg in terms of how
our parents experiences and our
experiences can be passed on from one
generation to the next both in terms of
modifying the biological circuits of the
brain and body and the psychological
consequences of those biological changes
during today's episode Dr rahavi gives
us a beautiful description of how
genetics work so even if you don't have
a background in biology or science by
the end of today's episode you will
understand the core elements of genetics
and the genetic passage of traits from
one generation to the next in addition
he makes it clear how certain
experiences can indeed modify our genes
such that they are passed from our
parent it's to us and even
transgenerationally across
multi-generations that is one generation
could experience something and their
grandchildren would still have genetic
modifications that reflect those prior
experiences of their grandparents Dr
rachavi takes us on an incredible
journey explaining how our genes and
different patterns of inheritance shape
our experience of life and who we are
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is Roca Roca makes
eyeglasses and sunglasses that are of
the absolute highest quality the company
was founded by two All-American swimmers
from Stanford and everything about Roka
eyeglasses and sunglasses were designed
with performance in mind I've spent a
lifetime working on the biology the
visual system and I can tell you that
your visual system has to contend Within
an enormous number of challenges in
order for you to be able to see clearly
under any conditions Roka understands
this and has designed their eyeglasses
and sunglasses accordingly originally
Roca eyeglasses and sunglasses were
designed for sport that is for things
like running and cycling and many of the
features they have reflect that so for
instance they are extremely lightweight
they won't slip off your face if you get
sweaty and they can indeed be worn for
running and cycling and things of that
sort however they also come in a number
of different Aesthetics and styles that
make them perfectly suited not just for
sport but also for wearing to the office
to work if you'd like to try Roca
eyeglasses or sunglasses go to Roka
that's roka.com and enter the code
huberman to save 20 off your first order
again that's Roca roka.com and enter the
code huberman at checkout today's
episode is also brought To Us by hvmn
Ketone IQ Ketone IQ is a ketone
supplement that increases blood ketones
most everybody has heard of the
so-called ketogenic diet most people
including myself do not follow a Keto
genetic diet that does not however mean
that ketones cannot be valuable because
ketones are one of the primary sources
of brain fuel and body fuel that allows
us to think clearly for long durations
of time and to perform well physically
which is all to say that even if you're
somebody who's not on a ketogenic diet
such as myself increasing your blood
ketones can be immensely beneficial for
cognitive and physical performance
indeed that's how I use Ketone IQ I'll
take one or two servings per day
typically sometimes before a workout but
most typically before doing about of
cognitive work so I'm going to sit down
and prepare a podcast or focus on
research for my lab or a writing project
or anything that requires a high degree
of concentration for a prolonged period
of time ingesting Ketone IQ prior to
that I've noticed greatly increases my
level of concentration and I can sustain
that concentration for much longer
periods of time than if I don't take
Ketone IQ if you'd like to try Ketone IQ
you can go to hvmn.com huberman to save
20 off again that's HP bmn.com huberman
today's episode is also brought To Us by
eight sleep eight sleep makes Smart
mattress covers with cooling Heating and
sleep tracking capacity so I've talked
about many times before on the podcast
there's a critical relationship between
sleep and temperature and indeed between
waking up and temperature that is your
body temperature needs to decrease by
about one to three degrees in order for
you to fall and stay deeply asleep at
night and when you wake up in the
morning in order to do that feeling
refreshed your body temperature actually
needs to increase by about one to three
degrees so it's critical that you
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that that temperature be
controlled very specifically across the
night and into the morning with eight
Sleep mattress covers that's all
extremely easy to do you can program the
temperature of your mattress in the
beginning middle and throughout the
night and when you wake up I've been
sleeping on an eight-sleep mattress
cover for over a year now and it has
greatly improved the quality of my sleep
and indeed I know that because eight
sleep also includes a terrific sleep
tracker built directly in to that
mattress cover if you'd like to try
eight sleep you can go to adesleep.com
huberman to save 150 off their pod 3
cover eight sleep currently ships in the
USA Canada UK select countries in the EU
and Australia again that's
eightsleep.com huberman and now for my
discussion with Dr ODed rojavi ODed
thank you so much for being here totally
my pleasure yeah this podcast has a
somewhat unusual origin because I am
familiar with your work but we
essentially met on Twitter
um where you are known for many things
but uh lately especially
um you have been focusing not just on
the discoveries in your laboratory and
other Laboratories but also sort of meme
type humor that relates to the
scientific process and we'll return to
this a little bit later but um first of
all I think it's wonderful that you're
so active on social media in this
positive stance around science that also
includes humor but today what I mainly
want to talk about is
the incredible questions that you probe
in your lab which are highly unusual
incredibly significant for each and all
of our lives and very controversial and
at times even
um a little bit dangerous or morbid so
this is going to be a fun one for me and
for the audience just to start off very
basically you get everyone up to speed
because people have different
backgrounds
I think most people have a general
understanding of what genes are what RNA
is and so on but maybe you could explain
to people in very basic terms and I'll
just preface all this by saying that I
think most people understand that if
they have two blue-eyed parents that
there's a
higher probability that they their
offspring will have blue eyes than brown
eyes
similarly to brown eyed parents higher
probability that they have brown eyes
rather than blue eyes and so on
but that most people generally
understand and accept that if they spend
part of their life let's say studying
architecture that if they have children
that there's no real genetic reason we
assume that their children would somehow
be
better at architecture because they
contain the knowledge through the DNA of
their parents they might be exposed to
it in the home so-called nature nurture
that's a nurture in that case but that
they wouldn't inherit knowledge or other
traits
and today I'm hoping you can explain to
us why eye color but not knowledge is
thought to be inherited and the huge
landscape of interesting questions that
this opens up including some evidence
that contrary to what we might think uh
certain types of knowledge at the level
of cells and systems can be inherited so
that was a very long-winded opening but
to frame things up
what is DNA what is RNA and how does
inheritance really work okay so DNA are
the is the material the genetic
instructions that is containing every
one of our cells we have the set of
genes containing the entire set is
called The genome and this is present in
every cell of our body the same set of
instructions
and genes are made of DNA and they're
all they also contain n chromosomes that
are containing chromosomes chromosomes
is the DNA and the proteins that
condense the DNA because we have a huge
amount of DNA in every cell that you
need to content it to sort of like um
thread on a spool right huge amount that
you have to condense
and we have the same genome the same DNA
in every
cell in our body can I just interrupt
and I'll do that periodically just to
make sure that
um people are being carried along
I sometimes find that even remarkable
that a skin cell in a brain cell a
neuron for instance very different
functions but they all contain the full
menu of genes and the same menu of genes
now it is amazing it is amazing and
perhaps it's good to have an analogy to
understand how it works so this is I
hope this is not the commercial but this
is like the Ikea book that you have in
every cell in your body the instructions
to make everything that you need in your
house the chairs the the kitchen the
pictures but in every in but in every
room you want something else so in the
kitchen you want things that fit the
kitchen and in the toilet you want
things that fits the toilet so you only
remove one particular page of
instructions which is the instruction of
how to build a chair and this you place
in the key in the in the living room
okay and in the toilet you put in the
toilet so the DNA is the instruction to
make the genome the is the instructor to
make everything this is the Ikea book
and in every cell we we take just the
instructions for make one particular
furniture and this is the RNA this is
the RNA this is the set and then the end
you'll build the chair the chair is the
protein so the DNA the RNA is the our
instructions to make one particular
protein based on the entire set of
possibilities
and and this is uh this is true for one
particular type of RNA which won't be
the style of of this conversation which
is messenger RNA
this is the RNA that contains the
information for making proteins in fact
this is just
a small percent of our of the RNA in the
cell so we have a very big genome and
less than two percent of each encodes
for this messenger RNA however
a lot of the The genome is transcribed
to make RNA that does other things
some of these rnas we understand
and many of them we don't
I think it's a beautiful description and
Ikea is not a sponsor of the podcast so
um it's a totally fair game to to use
the Ikea catalog as as the analogy for
DNA The Specific Instructions for
specific pieces of furniture is the RNA
and the furniture pieces being the
proteins that are that are essentially
made from RNA using messenger RNA right
okay thank you for that so
despite the fact that the same genes are
contained in all the cells of the body
there is a difference between certain
cell types right I would say is it fair
to say that there's basically one very
important exception which is somatic
cells versus germ cells and would you
mind sharing with us what that
distinction is so so yes every cell
every cell type is different because it
expresses it brings into action
different genes from the entire
collection and assumes an identity
and so we have uh we have cells in the
legs we have cells in the brain we have
in the in the brain we have cells
produce dopamine cells that
producerotonin and so on and we can make
uh different uh separation different uh
distinctions but we can make one very
important distinction between the
somatic cells and the germ cells The
Germ cells are supposed to be the only
cells that contributes
to the Next Generation that out of which
the next generation will be made so each
of us is made just from a combination of
experimenting egg these are two types of
germ cells and then they fuse and you
make you you get one fertilized egg and
out of this one cell all the rest of the
body will develop
and what happens in the Soma which is
which are all the cells that are not the
germ cells should stay in the summer
should not be able to contribute to the
Next Generation this is very important
and it's thought to be one of the main
barriers for the inheritance of acquired
traits inheritance of memory and so on
because for example like the example
that you gave in with learning
architecture if I learned about
architecture the information is encoded
in my brain
and since my brain cells
can't transfer information to the
Spearman D egg because the information
is supposed to reside in synaptic
connections between different neurons in
particular circuits that developed uh so
what's what what happens in the brain
shouldn't be able to transfer to the
Next Generation even simpler a simpler
example if you go to the gym and you
build up muscles you know that your kids
will will have to work out on their own
it won't that this shortcut won't won't
happen this is something that we know
intuitively and even if we don't have
any background in biology
and this is connected to the fact that
as we said in the beginning every cell
in the body has its own genome
and the next generation will only form
from the combination of the genomes in
the sperm and the egg
even if you somehow acquire the mutation
or a change in your DNA in one of
particular brain cells it wouldn't
matter because this mutation there's no
way to transfer it to the DNA of the of
the germs that will contribute to the
Next Generation
so despite that
there is as you will tell us some
evidence for inheritance of experience
let's call it or um and here we have to
be careful with the language right I
just want to put a big asterisk and
underline and a highlight that the
language around what we're about to talk
about is both confusing
and at the same time fairly simple and
controversial right it's a little bit
like in the um in the field of longevity
people sometimes will say anti-aging
some people say longevity the anti-aging
folks feel that longevity is more about
longevity clinics they don't like that
anti-aging is related to some other kind
of Niche clinics sometimes FDA approved
or government approved sometimes not and
so there's a lot of argument about the
naming but it's all about living longer
and living healthier
in this field of acquiring traits or the
passage of information to offspring what
is the proper language to refer to what
we're about to uh discuss
um there is this idea and I'll say it so
that you don't have to that dates back
to Lamarck and lamarckian evolution very
controversial right um and maybe not
even controversial I think it's very
like offensive even to certain people
this idea of inheritance of acquired
traits the idea that one could change
themselves through some activity use the
example going to the gym we could also
use the example somebody who becomes an
endurance Runner then decides to have
children within another endurance Runner
and has in mind the idea that because
they did all this running and not just
because they were biased towards running
in the first place but because they of
the distance they actually ran that
their offspring somehow would be
fabulous runners okay this lamarkian uh
concept is We Believe wrong so how do we
talk about inheritance of acquired
traits what's the proper language for us
to frame this discussion right we have
to be very careful as you said and there
are many complications that many
ambiguities and maybe you could tell us
why lamarchy and evolution for those
that don't know is so
um so such a stained thing right so it's
not polite right Perhaps Perhaps we'll
start we just just say that we can talk
about inheritance required traits
transmission of Parental responses
inheritance of memory all of these
things and we can also talk about
epigenetics
and transgenerational epigenetics and
intergenerational epigenetics there are
many terms that we need to
to make clear for for the audience
the the reason that is so uh toxic or
controversial is very
complicated and it goes a long time back
even way before Lemak so even the the
Greeks talked about inheritance acquire
traits La Marque is associated with the
term
but it's probably a mistake although
everyone talks about including people
who studied So La Marque worked he
published his book about a little more
than 200 years ago and he uh he believed
in The Inheritance acquired traits
absolutely but just like anyone else in
his time
just everyone believed in it this is it
seemed obvious to them that it was long
before Mandel and the rules of of
genetic inheritance and also Mendel was
long before the understanding the DNA is
the heritable material so this happened
a long time ago everyone believed in it
including Darwin Darwin was perhaps more
La Marque and De La Marque really yes
absolutely all right now we're now we're
getting into the yeah and and this is uh
in the inhale in in the origin of the
species it's in all of his writings
Lamarck didn't even really make the
distinction between the generations he
had many other reasons for being wrong
but he connected the terms inheritance
of acquire traits to evolution
and this is some of the reason he that
he was very controversial even in his
time there were other reasons for
example he rejected current day
chemistry and thought that he can
explain everything based on Aristotelian
fluids Earth Wind Fire and Water there's
still some people on the internet that
think they can discard with chemistry
and explain everything that's on Earth
Wind and Fire and this wasn't only
biology it was also the weather and
everything so that was part of the
reason but um
made many mistakes but he did have a a
full tier of inheritance which was a big
[Music]
um
step towards where we are today so he
had important contributions nevertheless
although he was mistake about the
mechanism what he believed like everyone
else
drives evolution is the transmission of
the traits that you acquire during your
life or the the things that you do or
don't you do we talked about use and
disuse of of certain organs that shape
the uh our organs and eventually also
the organs of the Next Generation he
sounds a little bit like the uh the
first self-help public figure right well
this idea you know I mean this is
heavily embedded into a lot of the
health and fitness space on the and
Twitter and Instagram and on the
internet which is that uh and it's and
it's the idea that we're sold
um very early in life at least here in
the United States and probably elsewhere
which is that we can become anything
that we want to become and then that
will forever change The Offspring
um either because of nature or nurture
right and this is a very dangerous idea
as I'll explain in a second and he led
to horrible things this is part of the
reason that this is such a Taboo it's
not only self-help you're helping your
all this helping yourself the problem is
when you apply to others and this
happens in a very very dramatic and
horrible way in in in recent in the
recent past as I'll tell in a second So
La Marque this is what he believed and
and he thought this was this is how
Evolution progresses progression and
later uh um Darwin
and showed that this really natural
selection the selecting of the the
people that of the organisms that are
already
um that already contain the the
particular qualities are selected based
on the whether they survive or not in
particular environments and therefore
the
um Evolution progresses they become more
common and take over this is very
distant two different explanations the
most common way this is contrasted is
the neck of the giraffes this is the
classic example according to to Lamarck
the giraffes had to stretch their necks
towards the trees
to eat when the treeter when the trees
were high and because of that they
transmitted these traits long next to
their children who also had long necks
by the way he only mentioned this
example you know
a handful of times he didn't really
focus on that and according to that we
just the agile that would happen to be
born with the long neck survived because
it ate so it's genetic heritable
materials you know about genetics but uh
take over and the rest of the giraffes
that have different heritable materials
just die
so this is natural selection versus
inheritance for quiet rates
there are many reasons why lamarchism
and inheritance of quiet rates became
such a bad term one of the biggest is
what happened in the Soviet Union
under Stalin there was a scientist
called lisenko who thought that
mendelism normal genetics is Bourgeois
science shouldn't be done and whoever
did normal genetics was either killed or
sent to the Siberia and and he thought
that just like you said we can not only
we can become everything that we want
but we can grow everything that we want
in every field we can take a frozen
field and grow potatoes there and so on
and this led to massive starvation
ruined agriculture in in in in the
Soviet Union also in science for many
many years and put a very dark cloud on
the entire field
and only probably in the 80s or
something like this the field started to
recuperate for that
aside for that which is a very dramatic
thing there was also crazy stories
around an attempts to to prove The
Inheritance required traits despite the
realization of many scientists this is
something that is very rare or that
normally doesn't happen is it that is
not a normal way that inheritance works
and I can tell you about two such
dramatic cases that will illustrate it
yeah please so so in the in the
beginning of the 20th century in Vienna
there was a researcher called Paul
camera was a very famous and and also
very colorful figure who did experiments
on many different types of animals
he did experiments on toads that are
called the Midwife toad because the male
carries the DX
and there's a beautiful book about it
from from Kessler telling the story of
what happened there and he there are a
couple of types of of toads some of them
live
underwater and some of them live on land
and these toads are different in the
shape and in the behavior
and so of course the capacity to live
underwater is one thing but also the the
morphology
and appearance changes the Toads that
live underwater develop these new petal
pads these black pads on their hands
that allow the males to grab onto the
female without sleeping for mating for
mating
and the ones online don't have them
he claimed that he can take the toads
and train them
to live underwater
changing the temperature and all kinds
of things it's a very difficult animal
to work with eventually according to
camera they will
acquire the capacity to live underwater
and also change the physiology and
develop these new black no petal plants
on their heads with this discovery he
traveled the world became very famous
and this was in just the beginning of
the previous century
as the person who found the true foreign
traits despite their controversy and so
on in their in the beginning of the
realization of how it actually works
with DNA and so on not with DNA but with
the natural selection DNA came later
and uh
and people didn't believe him he was
actually under a lot of attacks but it
seemed convincing at the end what
happened is that they found that he
injected ink to the Toads to to to make
them become black to have this new petal
pets so he faked the results
and
um and he couldn't stand that with uh
the the accusations and killed himself
wow in this book by Kessler it's just
maybe it was it was the assistant who
did it who killed him no no who who
injected it to to sort of save him from
because the sampers lost the coloring or
something like that so it might be who
knows what well in science whenever
there's a fraud accusation or
controversy that it's not uncommon to
see a passing of responsibility right
are there recent cases there are ongoing
cases now where it's a question of who
did what Etc actually I have two
questions
um uh before the Second Story
um I'm struck by the idea that he was
traveling and talking I'm guessing this
was before PowerPoint and keynote but
also before transparencies which are
actually were still in place when I was
uh
my graduate student for those of you
don't know transparency they're
basically
um transparent uh pieces of plastic
paper that uh that you put onto a
projector and then you can write on them
and do uh demonstrations but can show
photographs and things like that
um so how is he giving these talks and
would he travel with the top so he
traveled with the sempus I see and and
I'm basing this on this Kessler book
which is on its own very controversial
it's more of a beautiful story than you
know perhaps the truth but and and
according to the story there you had to
stand one side of the lecture hall with
his hands behind the back While others
would examine the samples and pass them
around and so on but he cheated someone
cheated he probably he probably did it
at least that that's the what most
people think
but this wasn't replicated I mean also I
don't think anyone tried to replicate it
interesting uh rep this is just a point
about replication and actually another
tragic example not but a few years ago
um Sakai who is a as far as we knew was
doing very accomplished work on um the
growth of retinas literally growing eyes
in a dish I think everyone believes that
result but then there were some
accusations about another result
um that turned out to be fraudulent and
Sakai killed himself right this was a
recent this was only about maybe five
ten years ago
um so it still happens yeah it happens I
think it's rare but it does happen
especially in this very high profile I
would argue I'd love to know what your
number is but I would argue that 99 of
scientists are seeking truth and are
well-meaning honest people I totally
agree and I think that uh even think
when people are wrong
it's mostly not because they're evil and
trying to active like maybe they really
want to believe the results or there are
all kinds of way to be wrong and and
even to bend truth without uh you know
just uh blatant fraud but this is
according to the story and an example of
very bad thoughts which is I agree it's
rare because most scientists as you said
this is also my opinion are just trying
to to discover truth and do the best
they can well why else would you go into
it because it's certainly not a
profession to go into if you want to get
rich and it's um probably not even a
famous if you want to be famous you
should go to Hollywood or um become a
serial killer because they'll make
specials please don't
um but uh please don't do either uh no
Hollywood I suppose for some is fine but
in any case
um okay so camera around 1907 1906. this
is slightly before the whole the the
Contour obviously broke out after the
first world war okay yeah great so um
camera is gone his toads with their um
either ink or whatever neupitol pads
they have to go back to mating on land
yeah okay I'd like to take a quick break
and acknowledge one of our sponsors
athletic greens athletic greens now
called ag1 is a vitamin mineral
probiotic drink that covers all of your
foundational nutritional needs I've been
taking athletic greens since 2012 so I'm
delighted that they're sponsoring the
podcast the reason I started taking
athletic greens and the reason I still
take athletic greens once are usually
twice a day is that it gets to be the
probiotics that I need for gut health
our gut is very important it's populated
by gut microbiota that communicate with
the brain the immune system and
basically all the biological systems of
our body to strongly impact our
immediate and long-term health
and those probiotics and athletic greens
are optimal and vital for microbiotic
health in addition athletic greens
contains a number of adaptogens vitamins
and minerals that make sure that all of
my foundational nutritional needs are
met and it tastes great if you'd like to
try athletic greens you can go to
athleticgreens.com huberman and they'll
give you five free travel packs that
make it really easy to mix up athletic
greens while you're on the road in the
car on the plane Etc and they'll give
you a year's supply of vitamin d3k2
again that's athleticgreens.com huberman
to get the five free travel packs and
the year supply of vitamin D3 K2 so so
this is forget about that we also had
the lisenko episode you know that's a
very big thing and and then in the US
there was in the 70s and 80s a
researcher named McConnell
who did very different experiments and
he was also a character he worked he
worked on he so he was the Joker type of
thing and he published many of his
results in a Jonah that he published
that was called worms breeders Gazette
and had many cartoons and so he started
his own journal yeah yes and that's one
way to publish a lot yeah but they also
published in in very respected journals
in parallel but he was he was a
psychologist American psychologist and
he worked on a warm which is a flat warm
which is called planaria which is very
interesting this is different than what
we'll discuss today different type of
one and you know worms are
are very common so four out of five
animals on this planet is a war really
yes numerically if you just count the
individuals so we are the exception and
and uh so but but I'll talk about a very
different warm later
this is a flat one this is called
planaria
and it is remarkable in many ways it was
also a model that many people worked on
including the the fathers of of genetics
of people who started genetics like
Morgan they worked on it in the
beginning but it's very very hard to
study genetics in this form because
unlike us unlike what we explained
before about how we all develop from
sperm and egg
these worms most of the time reproduce
just by fission they tear themselves
apart so they have a head and a tail and
the part of the head would just tear
itself apart on the tail growing you and
the head will grow and you tail the tail
will grow in your head you can even cut
them to 200 pieces each piece will grow
into a new one Wild and and they have
centralized brains with lobes and
everything and even this degenerate eyes
he studied these worms and he said that
he can teach them certain things
associations
by pairing all for I don't remember
exactly what he did I think it was uh um
either lights or electricity with shock
which would shock them with other things
and he could train them to learn and
remember particular things like either
you might get shocked on one side of the
tank exactly and then avoid that side of
the tank yes and then I guess the
question is whether or not they're all
they're ripped apart cells and their
subsequent Generations will know to
avoid that side of the tank without
having ever been exposed to the shock
right so without ever being exposed to
shock or they whether the the new
generation the new head will be able to
remember to learn faster that's another
the subtlety that you know might happen
okay
and and this is what he said it happened
he said he can teach them certain things
remove cut off their heads and new heads
with all the brain
uh will will grow and that it will
contain the memory this was the start of
the controversy not the end of it only
at the beginning
then he said something even much Wilder
which is it can train them to learn
certain things and then just chop them
up put them in a blender
and feed them to other worms because
they are cannibalistic they eat each
other and that the memory will transfer
through feeding this sounds such a
dramatic field
and by the way this this opened the
field so people did experiments then not
only in planaria but in golf fish and
certain rodents and did this memory
brain transfer essays implanting brain
and this is in the back when they they
had an idea that some memories could be
moleculars could have a molecular form
which is very appealing it's almost like
science fiction you can have a memo in a
tube
I like the way we think about memory
normally which is something that is
distributed in neuronal circuits
and encoded in the strength of
particular synapses and so on but but
the idea that you can take a memory and
reduce it into a molecule and transfer
it around is very very you know
interesting so this is why it's
attracted so many people this ended up
in a catastrophe
so there was an NIH investigation
couldn't no one can replicate anything
it was a big mess although there were
always scientists who said yes we can
replicate this in this so they were in
the background okay
McConnell stuff
was different
again people thought that they couldn't
they that there are problems replicating
but it wasn't necessarily but some
people replicate but it wasn't
necessarily about
replicating the whole thing but the
question was did the memory the transfer
is specific or is it an overall
sensitization that transmits and so on
right like you could imagine that what
gets transmitted is a hypersensitivity
to electricity as opposed to the
specific location that the electricity
was introduced or even more than that
more you're more Vigilant and you'll
learn anything except faster that's also
a possibility but his problem wasn't the
accusation it was much worse that he was
targeted by the Unabomber these
terrorists who sent letters with bombs
to many scientists for 15 years
and and his assistant again is the
assistant I think exploded and this is
how his line of research ended
just recently a few years ago a
researcher from Boston
um Mike Levin and and his postdoc
talshomrat
replicated some of McConnell's
experiment with the cutting of the head
but in the very using very fancy
equipment and automated tracking and
they could say that they can replicate
some of this his uh his uh his
experience really yes and they don't
open packages in that Library they have
they have interesting stories you should
have Mike over yeah I'm familiar with
with a bit of his work now I didn't
realize they had done that experience so
they published it yet a few years ago
and this is very interesting but of
course they don't know how it happens
the mechanism is unclear McConnell went
a step further than this and what's
fascinating is that this these are
experiments that were done in the 70s
and 80s he said that he can not only
transfer the memories through
chopped animals
but he can take the other animals that
learned and break it down into different
fractions so just the DNA just the RNA
just the the fats the the proteins the
sugars and he said that the fraction
that transmit the memory is the RNA
and this is very very interesting
because it was a long time before
everything that we know about
RNA today
I'll soon go into my research explain
what what we do and then you see that
you can actually feed worms with RNA and
get and have many things happen this is
everyone no this is true okay so this is
why it was so appealing to to go back to
that and study by the way at the time it
became popular knowledge everyone knew
this experiments they'll just it was a
Star Trek episode about it from 84.
there are Comics books about it books
about it so this was very and people
were eating RNA because they thought it
was ironing memory this was of course
complete nonsense but but this was it
made a lot of noise in these years which
is part of the reason it was so toxic
until recently you couldn't touch it
because it was considered pseudoscience
likely senko like uh camera and all of
this so this was just something you you
didn't want to touch at all
and and then we go back to to these uh
studies about the inheritance of memory
or inheritance of acquired traits in
other organisms
in in members in in in humans and aside
from the dark clouds that these episodes
left there were also theoretical
problems of why this can't happen
barriers that have to be breached for
this to happen
and you can you can talk about many
different types of barriers
uh
and and you can also narrow it down to
two main barriers first barrier we
mentioned it this is the separation of
the Soma from the German right the
somatic cells they can change in
response to experience the sperm and the
Egg the so-called germ cells cannot yeah
that's the idea or they are isolated on
what happens in the summer okay The Men
Who who first thought about this barrier
is called Wiseman August Wiseman this
one is the 19th century
so it is called today the Wiseman
barrier separation of the summer from
the German only the germline transmit
information to the Next Generation and
this is also called the second law of
biology so this is very very fundamental
so natural selection is the first one
this is the second one because it's so
important to how we work
to how our bodies work Wiseman by by the
way thought that if you will have direct
influence of the environment on The Germ
cells then perhaps this could transfer
to the Next Generation
so he wasn't as strict as
his burial suggests but but this is not
how most people remember it
okay but he thought that this is
unnecessary it's possible that natural
selection can explain everything and it
compared to to uh a boat which is in the
ocean it is sailing and it has a sail
open so you don't have to assume that it
has an engine the wind is blowing you
don't have to assume other things the
natural selection might be enough
so this barrier is still standing
but not entirely it is rich in some
organisms and we'll go into that in a
second the other barrier is the now we
have to to understand the other Bill we
have to talk about epigenetics we have
to Define epigenetics and what it is
and epigenetics is another term which
people misuse horribly and say about
everything that is epigenetics
even people from the field
the word itself that the term was
defined in the 40s by uh Weddington
Conrad Wellington and he talked about
the interactions between genes and that
and and their products that act that's
in in the end bring about the phenotype
of the consequences and how genes
influence development
later people discovered mechanisms that
are that that change the action of genes
the different mechanisms and started
talking about these as epigenetics for
example the DNA is built out of four
basic elements
is how the the the at GNC right and they
could be more chemically modified
so in addition to just the information
that you have in the sequence of the DNA
you also have this the information in
the modification
of the basis
the most common modification that has
been studied more than others is
modification of the letter c of cytosine
methylation the addition of a metal
group to this C
and
and and this can be
replicated so after the the DNA the
cells divide and and replicate the
genetic material in certain cases also
these chemical modifications can be
added on and replicate and be preserved
for those who aren't as familiar with
thinking about genes uh and Gene
structure and epigenetics could we think
of um these you mentioned the four
nucleotide bases cg80 but could we
imagine that through things like
methylation it's sort of like taking the
primary colors and adding a changing one
of them a little bit changing the the
Hue just slightly which then opens up an
enormous number of new options of color
uh integration it's just more
combinations more ways more information
there are the modifications of the DNA
and also there are the modifications of
the proteins which condense the DNA that
are called histones
so they are also Modified by many
different chemicals again methylation is
a very common modification acetylation
even serotonin
the serotonination of histones Serotonin
right this is a new paper from nature
from a few years ago can change DNA not
the DNA itself but the protein that
condenses it essentially how
um in the analogy I used before of uh of
how the thread is wrapped around the
spool essentially yes and and this
determines the the degree of
condensation of the DNA whether the gene
is now more or less accessible and
therefore can perhaps be expressed more
or less
this is this is one way to affect the
the gene expression and and bring about
the function of the gene there are many
additional ways not the only one
so then when this was when all of this
was starting to be elucidated people
talked about epigenetics they started
talking about these modifications forgot
the original definition and when people
said epigenetics they talk about
methylation and things like that and um
again to just frame this up so we can
imagine two identicals twins so-called
monozygotic twins
um we could go a step further and say
that they're monochorionic if they were
in the same placental Sac because twins
can be raised in separate Stacks
slightly different early environments
let's say those two twins are raised
separately one experiences certain
things
um the other other things they eat
different foods Etc and there is the
possibility through epigenetic
mechanisms that through methylation
acetylation
um serotonin production
Etc that the expression of certain genes
in one of the twins could be Amplified
relative to the other right so yeah so
we know that even a totally identical
Tweeds genetically they're identical but
they look different and they are
different because we experience we all
experience it and this is this can
happen because of these
epigenetic changes okay or it can happen
because of other mechanisms because
genes respond to the environment genes
don't exist in a vacuum
there are genes are need to be activated
by transcription factors and there's a
whole uh there's a lot of Machinery that
is responsible for making genes function
so we are
a combination of our genetic material
and the environment okay so when people
talk about epigenetics and talks that
talk just about the modification they're
also not exactly right my definition of
epigenetics is inheritance which occurs
either of course cell division or more
interestingly also for this podcast now
across Generations
not because of changes to the DNA
sequence by but through other mechanisms
I think this is the the the most robust
definition that that allows you to
understand what you're talking about
and then again and then uh and then the
question is if this happens then what
are the molecules that
actually transmit information across
Generations are they these chemical
modifications to the DNA or to the
proteins that condensate DNA or are
there other other agents that transmit
information and which molecules can do
it and I actually think that the most
interesting players today are RNA
molecules okay but before I go into that
I just want to say that when we talk
about the barriers to epigenetic
inheritance or the barriers to
inheritance of acquired traits
in addition to the
separation of the summer from the German
and we discussed the other main barrier
it's called epigenetic reprogramming
which is that we acquired our diff our
cells the the genetic material in our
cells acquires all kinds of changes
these chemical changes modification we
discussed
but these modifications are largely
erased
in the transition between Generations so
in the Gemini in the in the spearm and
the Egg and also in the early embryo
most of the modifications are removed so
we can start a blank slate based on the
genetic instructions
and this is crucial otherwise
according to the theory it's not clear
that actually true because in some
organisms doesn't really happen
we will just we will not develop
according to the
species typical genetic instructions so
to preserve this we we raise them at the
the all these modifications that start
anew and this is in memmers and in
humans
this is largely too most of the
notifications on this in the sperm and
in the egg are removed from about 90
percent of them some remain which could
be interesting so the idea if I
understand correctly is that there's
some Advantage uh to wiping the Slate
clean and returning to the original plan
in in the context of the IKEA furniture
analogy
um the instruction book is the one
that's issued to everybody okay or every
cell right only certain instructions are
used for certain cells say a skin cell
or a neuron or a liver cell or a
um any other cell for that matter
through the course of the lifespan of
the organism those Specific Instructions
are adjusted somewhat okay so maybe uh
like Ikea furniture uh sometimes you you
can they send you seven not eight of
particular screws where they send you
um the proper number but you put them in
the wrong place and it sort of changes
the way that the thing works a little
bit
once that assuming Furniture could
reproduce but here in the analogy of the
furniture as as the cell or or the organ
in that mates with another organism that
needs to be replicated and so the idea
is to take the instruction but go
through and erase all the pen and pencil
marks erase all those additional little
modifications that the the owner use or
introduced to it and return to the
original instruction right because if
you want to bring back the instruction
book you want it to have all the
potential to make all the Furnitures you
don't want it to be restricted to the
ones that you made in particular
room so it's essentially the opposite of
acquired traits and characteristics
based on your uh what we say in biology
geek speak lineage based experience but
what your parents experience right in
some ways we want to eliminate all that
and go back to just the genes they
provided yes but it's more complicated
it's more complicated than that because
we have some very striking examples even
in members were some of the of the marks
are maintained for example the classic
example is imprint imprinting is a very
interesting phenomena and
the way DNA works is that we you inherit
and a copy for every chromosome from
your mother and your father
and then you have in every cell of your
body two copies if you're a human
of every concept okay and then so so
every Gene is represented twice these
are called alleles the different
versions of the chief
and the the thought is that once you
entered in the Next Generation the two
copies that you inherited are
are equal it doesn't matter whether you
record inquire acquire them from your
mother or from your father right
there are some situations where it does
matter there's there is a limited number
of genes that are in Pre called
imprintages where it does matter whether
you inherited from your mother or your
father and and this is happening through
epigenetic analysis not because of
changes to the DNA sequence but because
of maintain maintenance of this chemical
modifications across generations and as
I recall from the beautiful work of
Catherine dulock uh at Harvard that
especially in the brain there is
evidence that some cells contain the
complete genome from Mom or the complete
genome from Dad and it can also switch
during your life so for her work showed
that early on in in your life it's
different whether you express the
maternal or paternal copy then when
you're
more mature so parents and children take
note you know for those of you that are
saying oh you know the child is more
like you or more like me that can change
across the lives man and if you're
thinking about your parental lineage and
wondering whether or not you quote
unquote inherited some sort of trait
from mother or from father it can be of
course both or it can be just one or
just the other which I think most
parents
tend to see and describe in their
children from time to time that's just
like the father that's just like the
mother of friends right right but
it's important to know that in this
situation their environment played no
role this was just whether it passes to
the mother or the father it's not that
something that happened to the mother or
the father affected this okay so this is
slightly different the question is now
can the environment
change the heritable material okay so
it's very important
to understand that there's a difference
between nurture and nature and this is
very confusing and people are
it's a little subtle so for example
people tell me I'm growing horses for
many years and I just know that this
horse has a particular uh character it's
very different from from the other horse
and so this is epigenetic and Heritage
no it could be just genetically
determined yes this horse inherited a
different set of genetic instructions so
it is different it doesn't have to be
about epigenetics epigenetic inheritance
means that the environment of the
parents somehow change the the children
and there there are these two main
barriers that are serious bottlenecks
that we have to think what type of
molecule and how they can be breached so
one possibility is that it's really this
limited number of chemical modifications
that survive and which is about 10 also
that could be very interesting not a
small number not a small number but
perhaps perhaps okay this is one one
possibility the other possibility that
there are other mechanisms
the the situation now in humans is that
it's just really unclear what transmits
if it can transmit and which molecule
does it
we'll talk later about other organisms
where it is a lot more clear but in
humans and members in general there are
many examples for environments that
change the children
whether they you need to invoke an
epigenetic mechanism to explain this
phenomena this is unclear first of all
because it's how to separate nurture
from nurture
and second because the mechanism is just
not understood so there are classic
examples for in humans there were
periods of famine starvation in
different places in the world
in the Netherlands in China in Russia
where people did huge epidemiological
study to study the next Generations and
so that the children of women who were
starved
during pregnancy are different different
in many ways they have a
different birth weight
glucose sensitivity and also some
neurological
higher chances of getting some
neurological diseases and this has been
shown
in very large studies is there ever an
instance in which starvation or hardship
of some kind some challenge a sensory
challenge or a survival based challenge
led to Adaptive traits yes they are in
different organisms
it could be as a result of a trade-off
so there could be a downside as well but
for example there are two examples that
come into mind one of them is that if
you stress male
um mice or or
um or rats I don't remember this is work
of Isabel mansoi in the eth in
Switzerland if you stress the males you
can do it in many different ways and I
don't remember exactly how they did but
you can do you can separate them from
their mothers you can do social defeat
all kinds of things then the next
Generations are less stressed they show
less anxiety so they're threshold for
stress is higher yes however I think
they have memory deficits and and other
metabolic approach maybe an advantage
for dealing with stress could be it
could I don't have any direct evidence
of that but there's some there's some
simmering ideas that you know our
ability to Anchor our thoughts in the
past present or future seems very
adaptive in certain contexts in other
contexts it can keep us ruminating and
not right you know right adaptively
present to our current challenge another
example is that uh um nicotine exposure
this is I think the work of oliverando
from UMass is a if I'm not mistake again
these are not my studies but they
improve the the tolerance to exposure to
similar drugs in the Next Generation
the interesting thing here is that it's
very non-specific so you you treat them
with nicotine but then in the Next
Generation they are more tolerant to
nicotine but also to other
I think cocaine or that sort of makes
sense to me because uh yeah obviously
nicotine
um activates the cholinergic system the
dopaminergic system epinephrine and Etc
um and you can imagine that there's
crossover because other drugs like
cocaine amphetamine mainly Target the
catecholamines the dopamine and
narepants in in this particular study if
I remember correctly they show that this
happens this heritable effect even if
you use an antagonist to block the
nicotine receptor wow so so it's
something more about clearance of
xenobiotics and and hepatic functions
that is transmitted and is very
non-specific what I love about all the
examples you've given today and and
especially that one is and I hope that
people um if you're just listening I'm
smiling because biology is so cryptic
sometimes you know the the the the
obvious mechanism is rarely the the one
that's actually at play right and um and
people always ask well why why is it
like this and I always say you know the
one thing I know for sure is that I
wasn't consulted at the design phase and
if anyone claims they were then you
definitely uh want to back away very
fast and there could be so many
trade-offs so many trades so for for
example we started and also other many
many other people studied effects these
are in worms we'll go we'll go deep into
that in a second but uh that show that
when you starve them the next
Generations uh live longer
and this I think could be a trade-off
with other things like
um like fertility
so the next Generations are more sick
and fair and less fertile and perhaps
because of that they live longer so they
could be it's not necessarily a good
thing right I don't want to draw you off
course uh because this is magnificent
what you're doing and and uh splaying
out for us here but do you recall there
was a few years ago it actually ended
very tragically it was an example I
think it was down in San Diego County
there was a cult of sorts that were
interested in
um living forever uh and so they uh
castrated the male self-castrated
themselves in the idea that somehow
maintaining some prepubescent data
reverting to a pseudo pre-probescent
state would somehow extend longevity the
idea that um sexual behavior somehow
limited lifespan this has been an idea
that's been thrown around in the kind of
more wacky longevity communities
um they also shaved their heads they
also wore the same Sneakers but then
they also all committed suicide right as
the hail Bop Comet came through town
um but that's just but one example of
many Cults aimed at sort of um that
obviously was not life extension that
was life truncation but aimed at kind of
eternal life or some sort of uh through
caloric restriction that's right this
this cult also is very into the whole
idea that by through caloric restriction
we can live much longer which uh may
actually turn out to be true I think
it's still debated
um hence all the debate about
intermittent fasting Etc but also uh it
isn't on if you overeat you shorten life
this is this is clear it's known that
big-bodied members of a species live far
um shorter lives than the smaller
members a Great Dane versus a Chihuahua
for instance so there is some like sort
of shards of truths in all of these
things but I I it seems to me that the
real question is like what is the real
mechanism and and why would something
like this exist right and why questions
are very dangerous in biology right
right but but very interesting also and
and so so when it comes to metabolic
changes and nutrition there are numerous
examples where you either overfeed or
starve and gets effects in the next
Generations many of the sometimes the
effects contrast depending on the way
you do this and again these are none of
we don't do any of that in in members
but people show that you're starving or
overfeeding the mothers or the fathers
changes the body weight of the the Next
Generation and also the the glucose
tolerance and and other and and also a
productive uh success and um
and and so the the fact that there's an
effect that there's something transmits
this is clear the question is how
miraculous is it and whether you need
new biology and epigenetics to explain
what do I mean by that if you affect the
Next Generation
it doesn't necessarily has to go through
the outside or the sperm and involves
the epigenome you change the metabolism
of the animal as it develops and
obviously it will affect it when you for
example starve women that are pregnant
as happened during the the this famous
starvation studies the the baby is
already in Utah exposed directly to the
environment so it's not even a heritable
effect the baby is itself that effective
it's a direct effect very interesting
important and has many implications and
it will be separate from the genetics
you have to take it into account to
understand what's going on
it doesn't require necessarily new
biology a new new biology of inheritance
not only is the embryo affected the
embryo while in Utah already has gem
cells so it's also the next generation
is directly exposed
and you don't need any new biology
necessarily to explain it and it doesn't
have has to involve genetic epigenetics
or epigenetics Etc it's clear to me that
in the female fetus the total number of
eggs that she will someday produce and
potentially have fertilized by sperm
exist but in males with a 60-day sperm
cycle leaves me the question to
fetal males males as fetuses living as
fetuses in their moms already start
producing sperm or it's the primordial
cells that give rise to sperm so I'm not
an expert so I don't want to go into the
details of exactly when in Mammoth but
but yes exposure of them of the mother
also affect the eventually the the the
the transmission of the father of
genetic information through the sperm's
father and there are also many examples
of just stressing the fathers affecting
the sperm and affecting the Next
Generation then if you go to the F2
Generation if you've got two generations
down the road not to the kids but to the
grandkids then it is a real epigenetic
effect because uh because you you
examine something that happens although
the next generation was was never
exposed to the original challenge so
when we say about epigenetic inheritance
in through the paternal linear through
the funnels we talk about uh two
generations
and when you go through the mother it's
three generations to talk about to when
you need to invoke some real epigenetic
mechanism and there the evidence becomes
much more scarce
in minutes
there are examples
more of less convincing the field is
evolving and improving a lot so for
example now
to many people use the cutting edges to
use IVF
in vitro fertilization or transfer of
embryos to make sure that you actually
it's the it's the heritable information
not the environment uh or and that it
goes through the germline
so this is something that is being done
now there are studies which I'm at the
three-parent IVF where they take the DNA
from Mom the sperm from Dad and they
take the DNA from Mom and put it into a
novel cytoplasm or no no or just you
just take the sperm and transfer it and
fertilize the the the an egg to standard
IVF yes yeah you can do it in many
different ways but this idea that you
separate the the environmental the
environment of the mother from The
Inheritance or the environment of the
father and uh to to control and separate
nature from nature the environment
becomes the culture dish yes yeah
so so the field is is improving people
do experiments that have a higher ends
or more replicates and better controlled
and there are some examples for effects
that transfer and it depends who you ask
whether people believe it or not
many geneticists do not believe it and
many people do believe and it depends on
the community there are strong
resistance
for many reasons some of them are
Justified some less justified in our
part of the scientific process of and
how things work because it's it's it's a
new it's challenging the Dogma so this
is very interesting on its own if you
ask psychologists many psychologists
believe that those heritable trauma and
things like that
population geneticists less so
so this really depends and I think that
we are just at a point in time where we
don't really know whether it happens at
to what extent and we need bigger
studies even if you think about normal
just genetic studies where people trying
to understand the genetic underpinning
of complex traits
like
um
anything that involves their brain
pretty much we now know that you need to
study many many many people so now this
big genome-wide Association studies big
genetic studies involve hundreds of
thousands of people no one did an
experiment like this for epigenetics
it's much more complicated because you
need to also take into account the
environment and to it's I don't I'm not
even sure we know how to design such an
experiment it's very very challenging
okay so so the part of the resistance
resistance to the ideal is based on
total theoretical grounds because of
these barriers
and because of the of the controversies
on the other hand
there's people that really want to
believe it people really want to believe
it
because
it sort of gives your life meaning
if you can change your B biology
through changing of your kids through
changing your biologists also
psychologically I can understand why
many people want this to happen even
shreddinger the same as a physicist so
he wrote a very important book in 44 so
this was before the the double helix and
the
um
that's it's called what is life this is
actually a book that was drove many by
physicists to establish molecular
biology it's very very important and he
talks about the heritable material it
also talks about Evolution and he said
unfortunately Lamarque is a more
inheritance of acquire trait is
untenable it doesn't happen
and you're right this is very very sad
or unfortunate because unlike Darwinism
or natural selection which is gloomy
doesn't matter what you do
the next generation will be born based
on the instruction in the sperm and the
Egg doesn't matter you can't influence
it of course you can give your kids
money and education but you can't
biologically influence it you can also
so
um one thing I'm fascinated by for a
number of reasons is partner selection I
mean in some ways you know we think oh
we we want to find someone who is you
know kind that does seem to be by the
way the primary feature at least in uh
the data tell us we had David Buss on
the podcast of how women like men that
people are kind there's also resource
potential there's also beauty or
um aesthetic attractiveness in males and
females Etc
um male male female female as the case
may be but in terms of reproduction
spermag uh male female obviously so
we're selecting for a number of traits
but presumably subconsciously we are
also selecting for a number of traits
related to Vigor and in the idea that if
we were to have Offspring with somebody
that those traits would be selected for
right and we actually have a
work on that in nematodes that I'll be
happy to tell you about in a second
after we with the dating and the data
the dating and warmth and and where we
understand the mechanism and we'll go
into that in a second but uh or in a few
minutes after we we dive into the worms
but uh but yes the original
um calculations of how population
genetics work
to simplify things and to do the math so
it would be busy it was random mating of
course it doesn't work like that okay so
it complicates things because we know
and there's research about potential uh
capacity to somehow sense uh immune
compatibility and things like this which
is I don't know I'm not an expert on
that but neither am I but my
understanding is that of course we're
familiar with the other traits we select
for um like potential nurturing ability
whether or not someone is reliable
predicts something about their nurturing
ability and for Offspring potentially I
mean you can draw lines between these
things without any um direct evidence
but but they seem so logical right that
somebody kind who might also stick
around or be honest in these kinds of
things that it makes sense but that one
would be selecting for certain
biological traits like immune function
or some other form of robustness that
we're not aware of is I think a
fascinating fascinating area of biology
yeah yeah so so this is where the the
the the
working members stand however there's
also one additional thing to to mention
which is that
on top of chemical modifications to the
DNA and and the proteins that condense
the DNA which are called histones there
are also other mechanisms that might
transmit information including
transmission between generations of RNA
and there are different types of RNA not
just the RNA that we mentioned before
the messenger RNA which
encodes for the information for making
protein but also other rnas that
regulate gene expression and this is and
I think that in recent Years also in the
mammalian field a RNA as the molecule
that has the potential to transmit
information between generation took
Center Stage so I think this is The
Cutting Edge
and a lot more to understand than no but
RNA has a lot of potential for doing
that as we'll explain uh soon but we
have to go to worms first I'd like to
just take a brief moment and thank one
of our podcast sponsors which is inside
tracker inside tracker is a personalized
nutrition platform that analyzes data
from your blood and DNA to help you
better understand your body and help you
reach your health goals I've long been a
believer in getting regular blood work
done for the simple reason that blood
work is the only way that you can
monitor the markers such as hormone
markers lipids metabolic factors Etc the
impact your immediate and long-term
Health one major challenge with blood
work however is that most of the time it
does not come back with any information
about what to do in order to move the
values for hormones metabolic factors
lipids Etc into the ranges that you want
with inside tracker changing those
values becomes very straightforward
because it has a personalized dashboard
that you can use to address the
nutrition-based behavior-based
supplement-based approaches that you can
use in order to move those values into
the ranges that are optimal for you Your
vitality and your longevity inside
tracker now includes a measurement of
APO lipoprotein B so called APO B in
their ultimate plan apob is a key marker
of cardiovascular health and therefore
there's extreme value to knowing your
apob levels if you'd like to try inside
tracker you can go to insidetracker.com
huberman to get 20 off any of inside
tracker's plans again that's inside
tracker.com huberman to get 20 off thank
you
for that incredible overview of genetics
and RNA and epigenetics and was
essentially a survey of this very
interesting
um and on the face of a complex field
but you've simplified it a great deal
for us
in our transition to talking about worms
I would like to plant a flag in the uh
in the huberman lab podcast and say that
what we are about to discuss is the
first time that anyone on this podcast
has discussed so-called model organisms
I may have mentioned a fly paper here or
there or a study on honeybees and
caffeine and um flower preference at one
point but typically that's done in
passing and we quickly rotate to humans
I know that many if not most of our
listeners are focused on humans and
human biology and health Etc but I
cannot emphasize enough the importance
of model organisms and the incredible
degree to which they've informed us
about human health especially when it
comes to very basic functions in cells
right I mean one could argue okay and
there's been some debate telomeres and
mice did that really lead to the same
sort of data on humans okay there are
these those cases certainly but model
organisms are absolutely critical and
have been and basically informed most of
what we understand about human health so
before we
um start to go into the description
about worms per se could you just
explain to a general audience what a
model organism is right they're not
modeling they're not posing for
photographs obviously
um what what that means and what some of
the general model organisms are and why
you've selected or elected to work on a
particular type of worm to study these
fascinating topics that in there's zero
question also take place in in humans at
some level
so it's it's a it's a real pleasure and
an honor to represent the model
organisms here I'm really happy just for
that this is it was worth it uh because
as you said model organisms are
extremely important and we learn so much
about about biology through them the the
model organisms mean that it's an it's a
an organism that many people work on so
there's a community of people that work
on people work study many types of
organisms but not around every organism
there's a huge community of researchers
that com that combine sources to create
all the the resources and the tools and
understanding that accumulates
there's just a handful of model
organisms
in the his in the short history of the
field of biology it's not so long we
learned about every aspect of biology
through them including many important
diseases
human diseases and these are
E coli bacteria phage which is a virus
of bacteria
and
flies
worms that are called C elegans
nematodes this is what we study in the
lab
fish which are called zebrafish it's a
particular Danny o'danio right yeah and
uh and of course there are also model
organisms and mouse
and um and also plants important plants
the most studies one is the arabidopsis
yeah and perhaps less so nowadays but
non-human primates macaque monkeys
marmoset squirrel monkeys these I I
don't know exactly how to finish this
but emerging model organisms there are
many logarithms that are emerging and
there are communities that are formed
including also around the planaria that
we mentioned before this flatworm that
regenerates is a great model for
studying regenerations if we could
develop new heads it would be incredible
and we can learn from these organisms
and the reason that we can learn a lot
also about humans by studying these
animals is that we all evolve from the
same ancestor
so we shared we shared we shared a lot
of our uh um uh our functions with them
and also a lot of our genes
see elegans and they have the different
model organisms have different
advantages that serve us
they uh they sometimes have some things
that are much more apparent in them that
we can study for example learning and
memory was largely studied in the
beginning in a snail Ecclesia where many
of the discoveries were made because it
has big noise that you can easily study
and
and examine and yes snails learn yes
they learn even CL against these
nematodes that we study learn and they
are much simpler than another important
reason to send them of course is you can
you actually experiment on them we can't
do this to humans the things that we do
to these animals and and we can change
their genes
do all kinds of things for them and in
some uh sorry to interrupt but in some
cases I think you're going to tell us
for instance in C elegans in particular
they what the presence of particular
cell types is so stereotyped that you
can look at several different worms and
you can the the community of people that
study CL against is literally numbered
and named each neuron so that two
laboratories on opposite sides of the
world can publish papers on the same
neuron knowing that it's the same neuron
of the two different Laboratories
something that is extremely hard to do
in any mammalian model a mouse or
certainly in humans and um has posed
huge challenges that uh give great
advantages to studies of things like
Clans
this is the star now of of what what and
this is what what we study these are
nematodes small worms round worms that
are just one millimeter long
so you can see them with the naked eye
you have to look under the scope where
do they live in the in the natural world
so they they used to call them soil name
I thought but this is not really true
there are there are in many places but
they're mostly in rotten fruits and
leaves and
um you can find them in the ground as
well but you can also find them and they
are free living so they're not parasites
but you can sometimes also find them in
snails
okay but but the best way to isolate
them is from rotten fruits okay yeah I
like the idea that they're not parasites
I'm one of these people that gets a
little squeamish about the notion of
parasites yeah so so they're not
parasites they're really fun to handle
because they're so small and easy you
just grow them on plates with Edgar and
E coli bacteria this is what they eat in
the lab you can just pick them with uh
um with a small pick wire pick and move
them around and change their their genes
and do many things to them but they have
many advantages for neuroscience
and for studying inheritance as you
mentioned they have always a certain
number of cells in the body so a seal
against nematode always has 959 cells in
its body that's it okay not 960. not 958
959 okay and out of which 302
are neurons
always 302 there's a huge debate now
over Twitter on whether it's 302 or 300.
I I mean I don't want to get into
trouble okay but people take this very
very hard I think it's 302 but let's not
get into it because I'll get into
trouble well we can equilibrate all
things here by you say 302 granted
you're far more informed in this model
organism that I am or ever will be I'll
say 300 and then we're balanced in terms
of partisan politics in the C elegans
so so it's and it's always the same and
each neuron has a name like you said and
when we not only does every neuron has a
name many of them we know what they do
so there's a few cells that are sensory
neurons that uh sends particular
chemicals in certain situations we'll
know that a chemical will be sent just
by one
there are the motor Neons and internodes
and all of that we know how many
dopamine neurons they are and serotonin
and we know them all by their name not
only that we know how they are connected
to one another we have a conectom since
the 80s
like a subway map that tells us which
neuron talks with which other neurons
and it is the same
okay it was used to think to people
thought that it was exactly the same
between genetically identical worms now
we know that there are slight
differences but by and large it is the
same and we have a map a roadmap that we
can use to study the so-called connector
the connector not only that the worms
are transparent
so we can actually see the neurons
fire
using particular tools
and we can activate genes and solid
genes using optogenetics like was
discussed in on the podcast we can make
the worms go forward or backward or lay
an egg by shining different waves of
length of light on them and so we have a
very powerful tools for manipulating the
brain
on top of that we have
a great understanding of the genetics of
the worm of of the genome this is
surrogance is the first animal to have
its secret its genome sequenced before
humans for that of course they were
bacteria but
and um
and we know that in each worm produces
each mother produces about 250 babies
which are almost genetically identical
so we can and we know what we get where
we grow them the environment is very
controlled so we grow them in the plate
with just bacteria so we can easily
separate between nature and nurture and
and one thing that uh I wonder about
often is Generation time you know even
um though mice are not humans mice have
certain advantages because they're
mammalian species you can't do all the
Magnificent things you can do in C
elegans and mice but
uh one major issue with mice is that the
generation time is somewhat long even
pair two mice they may you get a mouse
or litter of mice 21 days later it might
seem like okay uh that's only 21 days or
so but
if you are a graduate student or postdoc
trying to do a project I mean that can
extend the time to do experiments out
three or four years compared to what you
could do in Seattle again you're
absolutely right this is one of the
major advantages the generation time in
silicons is free days three days so you
can do hundreds of warm Generations in
one PhD this is very important not only
that every worm will produce hundreds of
opportunities so you will have that are
genetically identical so you will have
great statistics for your experiments
and the worms probably don't mind living
on these agar plates you know munching
away on E coli where
um it's the good life you know it's
questionable whether or not mice or
certainly listen I I I'm a proponent of
well-controlled uh over and as long as
there's oversight um animal research
it's necessary for the development of
treatments of diseases that that hinder
humans but it is always a little bit of
a of a kind of a cringe and go kind of
thing when you're dealing with with
mammals that are living so far outside
their natural environment you know I'd
be lying if I didn't say that it gets to
you after a while and if it doesn't get
to you you kind of have to wonder about
your own psyche a bit right I also think
that this is important but for me it's
much easier to work on worms I don't
have to uh you know feel bad about it
yeah they're happy if they're happy
happiness you also I mean if if a worm
dies it's less painful to the human than
if uh and other more sensitive animals
yeah I would argue yes I agree yeah so
yes there so there are many advantages
for studying C elegans and
in the warm
we now have very obvious and clear-cut
proof that there is inheritance of
acquired traits
so much so that I don't think that
anyone pretty much in the epigenetic
field argues against it well and in
large part thanks to you and the work
you've done so could you tell us what
was the first experiment that you did on
sale against that confirmed for you
that there is inheritance of acquired
traits because of course the best
experiments and experimenters
um always set out to disprove their
hypothesis and when the hypothesis
survives despite all the control
experiments and poking and prodding and
um attempts to contradict oneself then
it's considered a victory but it's one
that you have to be we all have to be
very cautious about enjoying because uh
of the tendency to want our hypotheses
to be true so what was the first
experiment where you were convinced that
inheritance of acquired traits is real
the first experiment I did was when I in
my postdoc
which I did with Oliver Hobart in
University of Colombia and
we set to test whether worms can produce
transgenerational
for long multiple Generations resistance
to viruses
well this is a very pertinent topic
which is a relevant and and
worms these worms don't have dedicated
immune cells like we do they don't have
tea sets or B cells they defend
themselves from viruses
very efficiently using RNA so in fact
when we started these experiments there
wasn't any natural vials that was known
to infect the elegans which is amazing
because viruses are very good as we all
experience now in infecting
and the worms are resistant to biosis
because of our RNA molecules short RNA
molecules that destroy viruses
and these are called small rnas
now we need to discuss them before I
explain my experiment
in um
2006 two researchers that were studying
C Elegance
Andrew fire and Craig may look at the
Nobel Prize
for showing that there is a mechanism
that regulates genes
that happens for small rnas what they've
shown is that if you
inject the worms with RNA molecules
which are which are double-stranded
they lead to the side to to they shut
off the genes that correspond that that
match in sequence to this RNA
so it's sort of like taking the specific
instructions for the coffee table from
your Ikea handbook and you insert a copy
of that into the book and in doing so
you prevent the expression of uh you
sort of erase the original page perfect
explanation perfect explanation and for
for they found it
was two strands is what starts the
response leading to the production of
small RNA molecules which are the ones
that actually find the messenger RNA and
leads to its destruction silence it so
you don't get proteins in the end for
that they got the Nobel Prize after
people found that this is conserved in
many organisms including humans and now
there are now drugs this was only in
2006 that the Nobel Prize the paper was
published in 98 there are now drugs that
use this mechanism
also in you in in humans and I'll just
interject and say that not only is it a
recent discovery in an incredibly
important one but Andy fire and Craig
Miller are also really nice people yeah
they just happen to be very nice people
and Craig Miller is an excellent um I
think he's a kite Surfer uh when I uh
the only time I've met him in person was
at a meeting it had a black eye and I
thought okay wow I guess he's also a
pugilist or something but turns out he
had done that kite surfing
um so scientists actually do things
other than um uh go to the laboratory
Nobel prize-winning scientists that is
okay I'll let you continue thanks for
allowing yeah incredible scientists and
there were also
studies in many organisms on the
mechanisms of how this happens it is
called RNA interference RNA interferes
in the expression of a gene in the in
the function of the Gene and it's also
also called gene silencing because these
rnas enforce the silencing of genes
instead of the genes being expressed
they'll silence it and you don't
manifest them function okay
already in this paper the first paper
that they published about this where
they've shown the double strand RNA is
what leads to the silencing or the
control they've shown
two very important things one of them is
that if you inject the worms with double
standard RNA
you don't only see the
action in the cell that you injected or
in the tissue that you injected but you
see it all over the worm's body it
spreads
it wasn't exactly clear what spread but
it was clear that it spreads you see
that silencing all over the body this
includes also The Germ cells so if you
inject the double standard just to
somatic cells
even to the head you will get also the
effect in the jump set and in the Next
Generation
okay in the immediate collagening the F1
generation the kids
so this was really clear proof that this
is inherited however
this is
just one generation okay in this
original studies
latest I've shown something which will
immediately remind you what I told you
about with planaria that you can just
take worms
and feed them on bacteria that produce
this double standard
and that the Dobson and the silencing
would move from the site of ingestion
from the gut where the bacteria are
eaten to the rest of the body and also
to the Next Generation
okay so before we left when I mentioned
this cannibalistic experiments of
McConnell with the planaria and now you
see that it can happen and and this is
not controversial at all this is being
done routinely every day by any
silicon's biologist in the world okay so
this has been replicated a million times
not only that you can also feed planaria
these other worms
with RNA you can just put it in chopped
liver and let them eat it and again this
will sandwiches throughout the body
okay wild okay and this is what we do
routinely we always when we want we use
this technique to see what genes do if
we want to see whether a particular Gene
is important for a certain Behavior or a
certain something
the way to studies is to neutralize the
gene activity and we do it by just
introducing the worms with double
standard RNA that correspond in sequence
that match in sequence this Gene this
will lead to the silencing disactivate
the genes activity and then we
understand the the effect stops we know
this genius is involved in the in the
function and we never want to just
examine one worm so we feed the mother
with double standard and then we examine
all of its children
so we can have the statistics over
hundreds of worms or thousands of worms
so this is validated and not
controversial in our land totally
routine is it fair to say that
McConnell's experiments have um chopped
blending up these worms really graphic
image blending up these worms and then
feeding them to other worms uh planaria
that those experiments can yes be
explained by
um double-stranded RNA which and through
RNA interface potentially it hasn't been
done yet we are working on it in in my
lab now in collaboration with other labs
fantastic but it wasn't published but
yes this this could be the explanation
okay
so um
so fire and Melody these experiments
some other people did these experiments
when I started my work I wanted to see
whether in addition to artificial double
strand RNA some natural traits can can
also transmit across Generations because
of RNA because of small organisms right
because um injecting rnai or um shorter
interfering rnas that is or
um you know putting
worms into an environment with an
abundance of inhibitory rnas as an
experiment it's very different than
worms experiencing something and then
passing on that acquired trait to their
offspring I mean it's a world apart in
my opinion because one is an extreme
manipulation that illustrates an
underlying principle the other is
something that in theory occurs in the
passage of of generations just naturally
we're going from the less artificial to
the more artificial the the advantages
just like with monologanisms that the
more artificiality is the easiest it is
to you know exactly what you did just
now introduce one factor and you can
follow the result so this is always the
trade what I did was in Oliver's lab is
to see whether
the magic part of the magic for the
worms resistance to viruses is the
capacity to transmit information in the
form of RNA molecules inhibitory
molecules to the next Generations
and it has been shown before in C
elegans that the worms resist viruses be
using this mechanism this small
organisms
in fact this is probably the reason that
this small organized evolved in the
first place
to get rid of viruses and other
um parasitic genomic elements
and this is a mechanism to fight them
and what I've I did is a very simple
experiment I took worms and I infected
them with a virus
when you do this this also has been
shown in the past the worms destroy the
vials okay
we demonstrated this very clearly
using a fluorescent virus
so when if the if the vowels replicate
successfully the worm just turns green
green and if the virus is destroyed the
worm stays black right this is very
simple it's a clear cut off it's not
this you don't examine the worm and ask
whether it feels good but you just see
this green light binary response yes
yeah
and so we we took worms we infect them
with the fluorescent virus they destroy
it this also has been done in the past
but then what we did is we neutralized
the Machinery that makes small rnas in
the
descendants of the worms so they cannot
make small rnas
from the start on their own because they
just don't have the genes that you need
to to make this more or less
okay and then we ask when we will what
will happen will will affect these worms
with the vowels will they be green
or black they can't make their own small
rnas so they can't protect themselves on
their own the only way for them to stay
black for help them not having the vile
supplicate is if they inheritance
modernized from their parents and this
is exactly what happens
all the worms progeny although they
don't have the gym
that is needed for making the small rnas
are black they sign the valves and this
also continues for additional
Generations okay so the the parent worms
effectively
put something into the genetic
instructions of The Offspring that would
afford them
um this let's call it an advantage in
this case right afford them an advantage
if they were to be confronted with the
same thing that the parents were right
and we know exactly what this Advantage
is the advantages are small rnas that
match the viral genome then just chop up
the device in the Next Generation and we
can identify these small rnas
in the inhibitor awareness in The
Descendants although they don't have the
Machinery to make it just because in her
we can identify them by sequencing
by RNA sequencing which is like DNA
sequencing you actually
get the actual sequence of the RNA
molecules and we can see that they
correspond to the values and they have
they inherited small rnas only if their
their parents were infected with them so
there's specificity there there's a
specificity yeah it's not some just
general resilience passage right I have
to be careful in drawing an analogy that
isn't correct and I want to acknowledge
that what I'm about to say with
certainty cannot be entirely correct but
the analogy that comes to mind in
mammals is this idea that if one
generation is stressed that their
offspring May in some cases have a
higher stress threshold the resilience
to stress I could imagine why that would
be advantageous right your parents have
a hard life they have Offspring and they
want their children to have a higher
threshold of stress because stress can
inhibit reproduction Etc and as I always
say you know at the at the end of the
day and at the end of life
um evolution is about The Offspring not
about the parents and every species
pretty much seems to want to make more
of itself and protect it's young one way
or another either through nature sure
through nurture this is a nature-based
protection of young is it fair to say
that in the mammalian experiment with a
passage of stress resilience
that
it could be RNA based that that would be
for perhaps uh set some new threshold on
glucocorticoid production here I'm
speculating but I and I want to
highlight that I'm speculating I'm
speculating with a reason which is I
think for people that are hearing about
this in worms you've done a beautiful
job of explaining out why model
organisms are really important but to
think about how this may operate in in
our in the passage of human Generations
I think is a reasonable thing to
entertain right and and it is true that
also in mammals
now rnas and small rnas are a lending
candidate for somebody that could
mediate the transmission of of
stress protection or also of harmful
effects to transmit between Generations
perhaps are going to do it however in
worms the rnas have one more trick
that we don't we don't know the
equivalent in mammals yet this is
something very crucial that we showed in
that particular paper in the first paper
which is so the effect that I described
this transmission of resistance to
viruses
through these rnas doesn't only affect
the Next Generation it also affects
multiple additional Generations so it
gets passed it's get passed and you have
to ask yourself how doesn't it get
dilute
why why isn't it diluted right because I
mean everyone produces 250 babies
so you dilute by 250 and if something is
diluted for four generations so it's 250
times 252 after four generations it's a
dilution of four billions completely
homeopathic would never work okay it's
just there's nothing left
The Secret of these worms is that they
have a machinery for amplifying the
smaller in every generation
this is called RNA dependent RNA
polymerase it's a a complex which uses
the RNA
find and once it finds the messenger RNA
just create many many many many small
rnas so they don't get diluted and they
pass on for additional Generations okay
and this is the the trick we later also
identify genes that regulate for how
long an effect would last
otherwise I mean if if in the beginning
we ask why does how does it stop after
one generation now we have to ask why
doesn't it last forever and it doesn't
typically we see that the responses last
not only with the valuable system but
also with other trades for a few
Generations three to five generations
we found genes that function as a sort
of a clock the time situation of the
inheritance what sorts of genes are
those
so we call these genes motek genes motec
I don't know how is your Hebrew but more
text me it means sweetheart in Hebrew
but the acronym is modified
transgenerational epigenetic kinetics
there are different types of genes like
that and for some of them if you mutate
if you disrupt their function now now
the effect would transmit stably for
hundreds of generations it would never
stop
because their role is to stop the
inheritance from going from from just
you don't want to carry over something
forever otherwise you would it will no
longer fit the environment of the
parents and you'll be prepared for the
wrong things
so this is important there are what type
of genes are they one gene that we
studied
it's called met2 it's actually a gene
that functions in methylation of the of
the proteins that condense the DNA so
this is uh and there are but when there
are other genes that affect also
production of small rnas
is there some mechanism that controls
the duration of Passage
in a way that logically links up with
the lifespan of the organism so for
instance uh I knew my grandparents met
them uh I did not ever meet my
great-grandparents and I certainly
didn't mean my great great grandparents
I could imagine that my great great
grandparents or my great-grandparents
experienced certain things that were
passed into their children and and uh
perhaps into their children but it seems
reasonable given that humans live
somewhere between zero and uh 100 years
typically what now 80 years is that the
typical lifespan more or less okay
that
the if I were gonna design the system
and again I was not Consulting the
design phase I would want an Adaptive uh
trait to be passed for two generations
because given the way that our given how
long our species lives and certainly
given the way the world looks now as
opposed to the turn of the previous
Century or the turn of the previous
Century different stressors different
adapt you know different life
environments
um and what I would want to pass on to
my Offspring I can basically hedge
pretty well I can place a good bet on
the next hundred years maybe the next
200 but I don't have the foggiest clue
what the world is going to look like in
300 years is what I'm saying make any
sense whatsoever it makes a lot of
service and really it we need to to talk
about two things in response to this
question first of all
um yes you can imagine that the reason
that the worms in hertz typically for
three to five generations is that this
is relevant to something that happened
in the environment for example uh we
also showed that when you stab the worms
it affects the next Generations again
for a few Generations which itself is
amazing right I just like want to
highlight that that I mean you can
imagine next generation is sort of like
a genetic version of be careful kids but
I'm going to give you this extra lunch
pack in your genome that protects you
against the possibility of starvation
but it's also saying and were you to
have kids right so they have it also
yeah so I have to but just I have to
just make a disclaimer that we not don't
know that necessarily it's adaptive
could also be damaged as I said when you
stop them the next Generations live
longer but this could be a trade-off of
a trade-off for fertility or something
so other labs also have also shown
following our work that if you start the
worms the next Generations are also more
resistant to household starvation this
sounds
this is not my artwork but this sounds
adaptive okay but whenever you're
talking about the adaptation you have to
sit in the context of evolution there's
also this famous saying nothing in
biology makes sense except in the light
of evolution and so it's very hard to
say without doing the lab Evolution
experiments we actually see who wins the
ones that it hurt or the ones who don't
hit who takes over
otherwise it's hard to talk about
whether it's adaptive or not but when it
comes to the duration of the response
yes it could be programmed to fit
something for example if you're talking
about starvation worms transition
between periods of starvation entrance
periods where they have a lot of food so
let's say they find an Apple for a few
Generations they will consume the apple
and then they will be styled for a while
perhaps this is the number of
generations that takes them to finish an
epic or perhaps other responses also to
higher temperatures
if you grow worms in higher temperatures
the orphans are different they change
how they mate is what I'm alluded to
before we're going to get back to this
because it relates to cold exposure
which many listeners and perhaps it is
somehow correlated with the uh um the
cycle of the year
okay but to tell you the truth I don't
know as I said we we um we go from the
more artificial to the less artificial
if double standard energy synthetic RNA
is the most artificial
starvation is more efficient more
natural but it's not starvational real
the real context of the world in a real
Apple it's a plate with or without E
coli bacteria but it's not an apple
on a tree exposed to the elements with
other worms with bacteria with all kinds
of complications and it could be that we
will see different durations of
heritable effects the more natural we go
it's just much less controllable and
hard to do
and again when we're talking about
humans part of the argument why people
who are the disbelievers I I it's not
about to say but you know the critics
say that this wouldn't happen in humans
as they say
you know the worms generation time is
just three days the chances that the
parents environment will match the
children environment is very high
because uh there's not a lot of time to
for for the environment to change it
plus they can go very far small
there are many examples of epigenetic
inheritance
in plants this is a big field where the
very established uh proof for
inheritance of a quiet rate for for
epigenetic enhance be more careful
epigenetic
in terms of quite a small loaded 10 but
in Clans it also happens and then you
also say these are sessile organisms
they can't run away so the environment
is more constant the ideas are maybe
just a quick example that I've heard
before tell me if I'm wrong I very well
maybe uh for instance a particular
species of plant that grows a a straight
maybe slightly bended stock might be
exposed to some environment where in
order to capture enough
um sunlight and other other nutrients
might need to grow in a corkscrew form
the corkscrew form can be inherited
several Generations this is an example
that I don't know but perhaps it's
something like that I seem to someone
will tell trust me the one thing we know
about podcasting and YouTube is someone
will tell us in the comments so uh Ben
please do we invite that right but
there's a long history of epigenetic
inheritance studies in plants with
excellent studies well controlled
showing that it happens also there so
this is very clear when it comes to
humans you could say maybe my kids will
go off to live in a different
continent and they will be on the
computer every day and everything will
be different so it makes less sense to
prepare them for the same hardships that
I experienced however this in my opinion
this is this argument comes a lot it's
not the best EX argument because it
depends on the scale
of how you look at things we experience
we meet for example I'm not saying that
this is inherited but in humans but we
experience the same pathogens in the
same viruses all the time so perhaps it
is worth preparing for them right again
I'm not saying that that it happens but
but it depends on the on the on the
scale well what you're describing makes
perfect sense and I do want to
acknowledge these critics whoever they
may be I do have the advantage that I
don't work in this exact field and so
I'm happy to stand um on Toe to Toe with
those critics now and say that at least
in terms of an inheritance of reactions
or adaptive or maladaptive traits to
stress or to reward when you talked
about nicotine before you know passage
of response to drugs of different kinds
not being specific to nicotine it was
sort of a more General
um passage of of some sort of
information related to reactions to
chemicals present in nicotine but other
other drugs
foreign
I have long been irritated
um and a little bit tickled by the fact
that people say oh you know we have this
system for stress that was really
designed to keep us you know um safe
from lions and saber-toothed tigers sure
but the Hallmark of the stress system is
that it generalizes I mean if I get a
troubling text message or if I suddenly
see a dark figure in the in the hallway
when I go to the bathroom at night that
I don't recognize
both of those have the same generic
response which is the deployment of
adrenaline uh in both brain and body you
know changes in the Optics of the eyes
quickening of the heart rate stress is
by Design generic and so one could
imagine that a passage of of some sort
of stress resilience
um or a maladaptive passage to stress
would be also somewhat generic and
that's actually advantageous overall
same thing with the reward system you
know and we have essentially have one or
two chemical systems of reward I mean
there's the opioid system and there's a
cannabinoid system but in large part
anticipation and reward is governed by
the dopamine circuits and anticipation
reward of an ice cream cone for a kid is
the same neural circuitry that's going
to be repurposed when they get to
reproductive age and they are
anticipating creating children with
their mate and assuming they want to do
that the double Energy System is going
to be engaged so ice cream sex
um you know uh stress to weather stress
to famine the the biology of these more
modal systems and especially in the
nervous system are again I have to be
careful with the words by Design are
certainly generic and so I don't see the
need for so for immense specificity I
mean it's not like we're um well covid
just happened so could you imagine that
there's the passage of a covid-19
specific resilience no I think what
would probably be passed along would be
some sort of if it does occur would be
some sort of resilience to viruses more
generally and that would be advantageous
right so I I agree and this
this opens the question of what is the
bandwidth of inheritance how specific
can it be does it make sense for it to
be specific and in the case of C elegans
the response can be very specific
through this inheritance of rnas which
are just sequence specific they don't
regulate the the control one particular
Gene okay
in other cases it could be a very
general response and and and and it's
very interesting to think about it when
we talk about inheritance of memories
which is the most interesting thing we
could imagine can brain activity of some
sort transmit at least in these words I
said no I I said it's disclaimer
multiple times in in members we don't
know times will tell in words we know a
lot so can worms transmit brain activity
to to do they have the specificity to do
it okay
before I'll say that I just say that we
over the years learned a lot about the
mechanisms that shuttle the rnas between
Generations we know about genes that are
needed just for that
about worms would be perfectly okay but
just don't have the capacity to transfer
the RNA to the next Generations we know
about genes that will make the responses
longer or shorter
we know about genes that prevent the
transfer of RNA between different
tissues
about genes that make certain smaller
than if so we know a lot about that and
then the question arises we can we can
finally ask can memory transfer between
generation
I think that first of all we need to
Define memory for that and the broadest
definition would be any change in your
behavior because of what happened in the
past
or in your response because what
happened in the past or because of your
history
the more interesting part of course is
to talk about memories that are encoded
in the brain
and the reason is that the brain is
capable of holding much more specific
and elaborate memories then I think that
any tissues that transmit transfer to
transmit RNA to the Next Generation and
affect the next generation is
interesting the gut muscles everything
but the brain
can synthesize
information about the environment and
about internal State and can also think
ahead and the most provocative thing you
can say is that you could plan how
somehow the fate of your of the United
Nations using your brain you know after
taking many things into the code this is
without talking to them right without
talking right an instruction so it's
again we go back to this instruction
manual it's like writing something into
the instruction manual based on your own
experience right and and can it happen
okay and what is the bandwidth can we
transfer specific things and and then I
have to agree with you that I would
imagine that what can transfer and I
could be wrong
is a general
something
sensitivity
okay
you can make technology to being
inflamed or not
hypersensitive to pathogens hyper vigil
something like this okay but it can also
be something very specific
now we have to we have to understand
that the brain
uses a different language than the
language of inheritance the brain the
way we normally think about the brain is
that it keeps information
in
synapses in the connection between
different Norms when you learn something
you make you make some connections
stronger and some other connections
weaker and you wire the nervous system
in a different way
the information in the brain is synaptic
and it is in the connections on the
other hand heritable information of any
sort has to go through a bottleneck of
one cell
the fertilized egg
because we all start from just one cell
so it cannot be in the connections
because this cell doesn't have any
connections without the cellular there
alone
so we do so heritable information has to
be molecular it has to be inside this
one cell so the question is can you or
do you translate the information this 3D
structural information of sim synapses
and the connection between brains in the
architecture of the brain can you
somehow translate it to heritable
information to a molecular form it's an
incredibly important and deep question
it brings to mind something that was
once told to me which as soon as I heard
it was obvious but was very important in
formulating my understanding of biology
which is that a map is just the
transformation of one set of points into
another set of points right so a map of
of the world essentially is just you
take the what's been drawn out in terms
of the architecture and the the
coastlines Etc and divisions between
states and you transfer that to an
electronic map or a piece of paper it
seems so obvious it's sort of a duh why
are we talking about this but just to
make sure that people understand what
you're really talking about is let's say
the memory and I have a very distinct
memory for my childhood phone number
phone number doesn't exist anymore
and I won't give it out because then
some other person might get your
attention with repeated calls but in any
case I remember it it's totally useless
information but it lives in my you know
cortex or my hippocampus or somewhere as
a series of connections between neurons
at the locations as you call synapses
would my grandchildren know that phone
number there's no reason absolutely no
no right would my children know that
unless there was some adaptive reason or
some other reason for them to know and
the up and this passage of acquired
traits
um and what you're saying is in order
for that to happen there has to be a
transformation of the neural circuit
literally the wiring of Neuron a b c d
that relates to and carries the
information of that number into the kind
of nucleotide sequences that are
contained in DNA or patterns of
methylation or RNA more likely so it's
the transformation of one set of points
in physical space to a translation of
points in genetic space right is that
amazing right and then we have many
problems when first of all we don't know
of a mechanism to translate between the
two different languages the language of
the brain and the language of
inheritance we are not familiar with a
mechanism like that second the Next
Generation
if it's not a worm if it's a mammal
would have a different brain
if and if it's if even if it was
genetically identical to the parrot the
the wiring of the brain and the
particular neurona circles will be
different
this is true for twins it will always be
true because it depends because it's
partly random and it depends on the
environment even if you have the same
genetic instructions so let's say you
somehow had a mechanism a miracle
mechanism to take the 3D information and
translate it to the magic to the
language of inheritance you would then
in the Next Generation have to translate
it again to the brain although it is
different this sounds very unlikely okay
I I I'm playing a trick on you now okay
because okay but I'm easy to tricks but
but but if if this is how it happened or
if this was required it could never
happen in my opinion which means and I
still think that there are certain
memories that cannot transfer
transgeneration and these complex and
things that you learn about the
environment that are arbitrary
if none of our listeners kids will
remember this conversation
no way this is impossible unless they're
listening there are some families or
parents but but it cannot transmit
because it's it's random and it's these
are connections that are arbitrary
so this seems to be a limitation on what
can transfer
on the other hand so perhaps more
General things could pass some these
type of things I doubt they can miss
however you can never the less imagine
that some things that are very specific
some memories that are very very
specific could nevertheless transmit
from the brain after learning to the
Next Generation I'll give you an example
you can teach worms even if although
they have just 302 neurons you can teach
them simple things about the world for
example you can take an auto that their
worms like the worms have thousands of
other ant receptors and they can
recognize many many many molecules they
can smell them so they can find food or
avoid enemies you can take a food that
the worms like an order that the worms
like and pair it to something bad like
starvation
and then the worms will learn to dislike
this Auto
we don't know that this learning
involves necessarily changing in the
strengths of synapses it's a possibility
but it doesn't have to be the case it
could be that just the receptor for this
particular order
is being removed
when they and this is how they now they
won't have the receptor they won't smell
they won't like the auto this is a
possibility
this type of thing you can perhaps not
that anyone has showed it convincingly
transmit to the Next Generation because
all it would take is an RNA that would
will control this particular receptor
okay
so this is a possible people have shown
things like that not in C elegans but
people have shown things like this in
mammals
they said that you learn certain things
and then
just in the next Generation that's a
particular receptor would be methylated
or would change and this would transmit
the response and on the one hand it
could be
true on the other hand you need to
understand they'll need to prove and
this wasn't done convincingly enough yet
how exactly does the information
transfer from the brain to The Germ
cells and then in the Next Generation
from the germs it's back to the brain to
where the reception receptor need to
operate
and this is a challenge this is the
current state of of the field that this
is something that needs to be proven
what we didn't see Elegance is we showed
that certain that the brain can
communicate with the next Generations
using small rnas
and that this can change Behavior
and it doesn't require any translating
between any language it is very simple
what we've shown is that if you take a
worm and you change the production of
smallerness just in its brain
in the next Generations their behavior
will be different even though you don't
mess with their brains this is a paper
that we published in
2019 in in cell we show that you just
manipulate the production of endogenous
natural rnas in the worms brain that are
always made but you you change the
amount and this changes the capacity of
the worms in the Next Generation to find
food
to find not only in one generation but
three generations down the road
and the way that it works is that
perturbing the production of these
smallerness in the brain effects in the
end the expression of a gene in the
germline
it's one gene this is called sage two
don't know how it works
but we can do all kinds of controls
where we manipulate the activity of the
Gene and see that this also affects
Behavior
and this Gene
works in the jumpsuit the information
needs to go from the brain to the
Genesis it doesn't need to go back from
The Germ cells to the brain to affect
Behavior and this depends we know that
this is there are two epigenetic effects
because it goes on for multiple
generations and also because it requires
the machinery
the transfers organized between
Generations if you don't have that
protein that physically carries the RNA
between generation doesn't happen so it
has to be RNA it has to be RNA and not
we can actually we can also find the
rnas in the Next Generation the change
we sequence the actual rnas the change
in the Next Generation you mentioned
that you don't know what Sage this Gene
Sage does but is it reasonable to assume
that it does something in the context of
the nervous system or that's unclear as
well it is possible it is possible but
we have reasons to believe
or experiments to show although there
could be alternative explanations that
it functions for the germi now you may
ask how can you affect Behavior just by
changing the germ cells right well it
would have to change the germ cells in
very specific ways because as uh people
probably recall the germline The Germ
cells are where the inheritable
information is contained but you can
imagine it for instance
um adjusting the gain or sensitivity
rather on some sort of uh
sensory foraging system right right and
the the interesting thing is it again
can be quite unspecific
so it sounds weird that you change germ
cells and it changes Behavior
experimenting but if you think about it
it's trivia if you castrate a dog it
behaves differently right
sadly yeah I did that to my dog and I
ended up putting him on testosterone
therapy later and it brought him back
yeah just as a as a sign as an aside yes
this is because the germ cells affect
the Soma including the brain in many
ways by secreting certain chemicals and
also because the other cells develop
develop from the from the germ cells so
some information could be transmitted
over a development or the course of
development could be altered because of
changes that occurring in The Germ cells
and for example in mammals one of the
explanations for how heritable
information transmits is that it just
affects something very own in
development
I I I told you that the secrets to
warm's inheritance is that they have the
capacity to amplify these smallerness
all the time this is what keeps it going
and prevents the dilution in mammals we
don't know of such an amplification like
them so you ask how can a little bit of
RNA or something without amplifying
affect the entire organism and it could
be that you just perturb something in
the very beginning
when you just have a few sets or even if
the in the placenta that develops in
pregnancy and these letters throws
everything off and because of the U.S
you have many problems in metabolism and
so on and this is called the the it's an
idea of the developed developmental
origin of health and disease many of the
of the functions occur early on in
development
so you raise a number of incredibly
fascinating aspects of this I do have a
question about one particular aspect and
feel free to pass on this for a future
episode if it's going to take us too far
off track but something you said it
really captured my attention
um although I was listening to all of it
which is that the germ cells so in the
case of males it's going to be sperm and
in the case of females it can be eggs
something perhaps not coincidental about
those cells in the environment that they
live in is that yes they contain the
genetic information to pass The
Offspring right of course you explain
how that works
but also it's a
it those cells live in a region that is
Rich with hormones that can be secreted
and in fact are secreted and through
so-called endocrine signaling
communicate with other cells not just at
the level of receptors on their surface
but also can enter the genomes of those
cells and modify those cells in other
words it seems to me that the micro
environment to The Germ cells the testes
and the ovaries
are rich with information not just for
the passage to next Generations but also
for all the as you said all the somatic
cells of the body they're telling the
somatic cells of the body what to do and
what to become and the best example I
can think about this would be puberty
right I mean I would argue that the that
one of the greatest rates of aging and
and transitions we go through in life is
from puberty I mean a child becomes a
very different person after puberty they
look at the world differently they think
about it differently the growth of it's
not just about the growth of the hair
and the jaw and the atoms apple and
breasts and so on it's a transformation
of the somatic cells from the same
microenvironment that the DNA containing
uh cells reside right so once you think
about it like this it becomes obvious
that just by affecting the germ cells
you can affect the rest of the body and
in C elegans they are experimented show
it very clearly so for example if you
take just take worms and prevent sperm
production it changes the capacity to
smell
these are experiments done by others
which is obviously a brain function and
in a castrated dog you're not just
eliminating the possibility of transfer
of DNA information to subsequent uh
Generations you're also limited
personification of the yeah without
question my Bulldog Costello change
after castration and it was a wonderful
dog but at some point developed some
health issues the introduction of a
small amount of testosterone every other
day
changed him fundamentally in that case
for the better
um back to a version of himself that I
had only observed earlier but also a
different version of the same dog and no
he wasn't humping everything maybe the
occasional knee
um particular people who has names I
won't mention but
it was absolutely clear that the hormone
was not just taking a system and
amplifying it it was actually modifying
the system so anyway I just wanted to um
highlight that and then now um thank you
for indulging me I let's
um if you will let's continue down this
path of uh that we were going on because
I want to make sure that we absolutely
get to this issue of transmission of
information about sex choice of
Offspring so the worms are
hermaphrodites which means that they
make both sperm and egg but there are
also males which are much more rare and
they can choose to mate with their males
or not
and when they made with the male it's a
huge decision because it's very costly
energetically and they also risk
predation
and all kinds of troubles the males hurt
them and reduce their lifespan when they
met with them people are going to draw
all sorts of analogies here but it's
inevitable but hey here we go and and
most importantly for evolution when you
mate
with another animal you dilute your
genome in half
because the worms can just
self-fertilize and transmit the exact
same genome to the Next Generation but
when they make they dilute it in half so
this is a big
price to pay on the other hand when you
mate you diversify your genome so maybe
some combination of Gene will be good
and we know that in humans I mean you
know it's kind of interesting that the
brain circuits are associated
um with a with aversion and with
approach are um are fairly hardwired for
a number of things like puddle of vomit
almost everybody kind of cringes plate
of cookies if you like cookies you move
towards it but there's one particular
word in uh the English and presuming the
Israeli language that that ought to
evoke disgust and that's incest because
incest is actually not just disgusting
as a practice but it's dangerous
genetically right because of the
inbreeding creates a deleterious
mutation right so there are studies on
how people in Israeli kibbutz for
example where they all grow together the
children live together it used to be
like that don't date each other because
this is the classic thing I talked to
some of whom the keyboards you told me
that's not true but but yes that there
are studies like this that say but it
makes sense and in some countries
Scandinavian countries are in a Lapland
and Iceland where populations are small
they keep Exquisite records of lineage
in order to avoid inbreeding right yeah
right so you're absolutely right but the
worms it's the safe choice for them is
to self-mate and and if they mate with a
male they take a risk but they diversify
okay
what what we found is that if you take
the hermaphrodites the the we can call
it the the female for just one second
and you stress it with high temperatures
then the next Generations of worms for
three generations made much more with
males
and they do it because the female starts
secreting a pheromone that attracts the
males Ah that's very cryptic uh
mechanism it's not that she somehow
changes and then goes seeking males it's
not it draws males it draws men oh and
we know how it works we think we know
how it works what happens is that the
stress the high temperatures compromise
the production of sperm in the
hermaphrodites so the hermaphrodite
don't they make sperm enough to make
make Generations but the sperm because
of the effective small RNA inheritance
because the rnas are not inherited okay
the spam is not made optimally so they
make less sperm and where they don't
make a lot of sperm they feel that they
don't self-fertilize correctly so they
call the males by secreting the
pheromones so that it would provide its
own sperm and they can continue to make
babies
okay and we know this also from
experiment you just take hermaphrodites
and you kill it sperm it starts to
kissing the pheromone and the males come
it's a need based system exactly
incredible and I hope people can
appreciate as they're hearing this that
none of this we assume I don't know how
to speak worm none of this we assume is
a conscious decision in these animals
they much like human mating behavior
which to us always seems so conscious
but is being governed by both conscious
and subconscious decision making
none of this is an active decision to
secrete the hormone to draw in more
males it's simply a biasing of
probabilities right the hormone is now
secreted in Greater quantities or more
greater frequency the males therefore
approach more so it's just increasing
probability of interactions is that
right right what happens naturally
normally if you don't stress the the
ancestors is that the worm starts
secreting the phalmon only when they are
old because also you know people will
when they're running when they're
running out of of their own fertility
exactly because they only make the sperm
at a particular time and then they run
out of stealth stem they can sell
fertilize so they have to call them as
if they want to continue to meet well
this is sort of the plastic surgery
approach okay I'll take the heat for
that one but you know but it's true I
think as certain people age to a certain
point and they feel that their fertility
is waning if they want Offspring they
need to take any number of different
approaches they could get a here we're
talking about a female but we could also
do the reverse right
um uh sperm donor right or by the if
they want to attract a lifelong maid or
co-parent with somebody oftentimes they
will do things to adjust their
attractiveness in any number of
different ways psychological
attractiveness or physical
attractiveness I'm not afraid to bring
this up because I think that the
parallels are very important because I
do think that every species and
individuals within a species of course
decides whether or not they want to
reproduce or not but has an inherent
understanding conscious or subconscious
about where they reside in the Arc of
their lifespan I do believe that not
just based on experience some people are
very attuned to the the passage of time
being very fast others very slow I think
that knowing how long your parents and
their parents lived makes a big
difference I have friends whose fathers
in particular died fairly young and all
these guys basically got married and had
kids really young right so here that
luckily for me I don't have to get into
psychology of the worms the explanation
is just like an instinct when they run
out of sperm it starts to keep the
pheromones and attract the males there
are studies also in human about older
fathers that children of older fathers
have more has a higher chance of of
becoming autistic there are study 40 and
up basically however in this case it's
not clear that this is not that this is
something epigenetics could be just
because of DNA damage you know because
it accumulates yeah and actually
nowadays there we have an episode on
fertility coming up both male and female
fertility and there's um they're
actually DNA fragmentation kits for uh
at home DNA fragmentation kits or sperm
analysis you send the sperm back in you
don't do the DNA people pipetting
um semen at home wouldn't be an odd
picture let's not go there but the um
but there are clinics that do this for
uh for a nominal charge but the um but
it's I did want to ask about autism and
human disease in particular
um another thing that you hear sometimes
and here I want to acknowledge autism is
on a spectrum some people get upset if
you call it a disorder there are some
adaptive autistic traits and Etc but one
thing that
um often comes up is this idea that two
people who are more of the kind of
engineering hard science if you will of
phenotype mate and have children higher
probability of the The Offspring being
on the Spectrum some people would argue
ah but that's already selecting for
people that might have already been
partially on the Spectrum so maybe it's
a gene copy issue I'm not asking you to
comment on autism in particular but when
you hear things like that that the
children of older fathers
um born from older fathers 10 a higher
probability of autism what is that at
the level of intuition does that strike
you as an epigenetic phenomenon as a
nature nurture mishmash or the
possibility that it's RNA passage or
anything does anything sort of um
trigger the whiskers uh your your spidey
sense so in that case I would go with
the most parsimonious explanation which
is it just less Fidelity or ever than
less DNA maintenance and some damage
that passes on it doesn't have to be an
epigenetic thing but the sperm are
generated at once every 60 days so the
damage must be at the level of The Germ
cells not having the proper Machinery
right might have chondria or something
like that or the DNA repair Machinery
the DNA repair Machinery could be
defective or could work less well in
older people leading to the constant
production of germ cells with more
mutation this is the possibility do we
know exactly what the DNA repair
Machinery is yes there are many types of
DNA repair
those one that use other copies of the
DNA to to uh to correct there are ones
that just recognize all kind of lesions
on the DNA and and remove it that it's a
very elaborate and complicated system
and is it a system that is now tractable
that can be modified through
pharmacology or through anything like
that so I don't know about drugs that
correct that improve it maybe they exist
and I'm not aware that it's very well
understood and many people are studying
this direction yeah one thing that um
came across in the exploration of the
fertility work is that what I'm about to
describe is not legal in the US it is
illegal but is illegal in the UK and in
other countries is this notion of three
parent
um IVF where it does seem that some of
the eggs that persist in older females
um don't uh even if fertilize don't
produce healthy embryos they have
chromosomal abnormalities replications
and and
um deletions that are problematic for
the development of the embryo
such as trisomy 21 AKA Down syndrome in
part or in large part because of
deficits in the mitochondrial genome so
what they now do is they take the um
because the mitochondrial genome resides
mainly in the cytoplasm they'll take the
an egg from the mother the sperm from
the father but they'll take the nucleus
from the mother
and put that into a cytoplasm of a
younger woman whose mitochondrial DNA is
healthy then use the sperm to fertilize
that egg and it and that's why it's
called three parent IVF then implant
that into the mother and this has been
done several times for in cases of
mitochondrial damage or or mutations in
the in the mother it works the question
is whether or not those Offspring will
grow up to be healthy so this of course
is not just a pure Divergence it raises
a bigger question that I have for you
which is
in terms of the work in either C elegans
or in other model organisms but in
particular in C elegans where do you see
this going next and if you would indulge
us I would love you to tell us a little
bit about the admittedly unpublished
work that you're doing on temperature uh
exposure and environments I mean how
malleable is this system because to me
it just seems incredibly malleable and
yet it a lot of us still cloaked off to
us there's still a ton to learn so
assuming that we will discover
similar things in in humans which we
don't know that this is the case but
let's say we we find it I think there
are many things you can do before you
change it
for example you could you could also
change it change
aberrant inheritance by having the the
parent exercise for example and some
things like this have been done for
example there are experiments in in
rodents where they show that overfeeding
the the Roland creates problems for the
next Generations for the F for the
children however if you let the the
rodent exercise then it corrects the
apparent inheritance so this is one
possibility and you can also manipulate
it at uh at the source you can change if
it's rnas let's say you could in the
future perhaps if we understand how it
works actually change the composition of
the Heritage by eating rnas just like
the worms RNA sandwich no so the RNA
sandwich will be difficult because it's
not I don't know but you could if you do
IVF if you do any veto fertilization you
can perhaps change the composition of
the rnas in the the stuff that you
introduce
but way before that what you could do
perhaps even in the not so far future is
use this for Diagnostics
dna-based diagnostics for every couple
that wants to have a kid uh you can in
Israel this is done for for most couples
you can look at the DNA and look for
genetic disease but no one looked is
looking at the RNA at the moment if you
understand how it works better we'll
have another level A Whole New World to
look at and perhaps there will be some
rnas that correlate with disease
that they will say okay you know but the
beauty is that this Unlike DNA it's
plastic so with DNA this is your DNA
perhaps we can choose another embryo
but here you could say
perhaps again in the future this is
science fiction doesn't happen now but
if we understand this and it's true we
can say
maybe you should run on the treadmill a
little bit this will change the profile
of your rnas and then we will use it for
IVF
this seems more because just it
correlates with healthy profiles of rnas
this is the level that no one looks at
now and holds great potential again with
a disclaimer that we know know how it
works in humans at all yes yes well of
course this is why why why it's so
interesting yeah yeah it's super
interesting
um incredibly promising so along the
lines of things that one can do in the
short term and
your experiments on C elegans I'd love
for you to share with us what you're
observing about cold exposure and how
that impacts subsequent generations of c
elegans and uh and if you would indulge
us with the story of this discovery
um like some of the earlier stories you
told us it is a surprising and
fascinating one I'll let me tell you
about it this is not a story about trans
International it's a story about memory
within one generation ah excuse me
within one generation okay and and as
you said the story of how it happens is
it's it's it's totally by accident it's
a funny story and I'm I'm bringing this
up because I know Donna lanchez was a
huge fan of your postdocs really you
know be happy that this is her work this
is her work and this is unpublished work
it's even we didn't even finish it so
we're working it okay well when it's
published we will feature the paper
because I love this story so great so so
what happened is that when you we talked
about transgenerational memories and I
said that in worms there are very
long-term generational memories if a
generation time for syrians just three
days
some memory is less so
many generations so Way Beyond the the
lifespan of the of the one the lifespan
of the worm is three weeks okay
generally you have a new generation
every three days but every worm lives
for three weeks
but there's a lot of research that shows
that unlike heritable memory which can
be very long the memo is that the worms
acquire during their lifetime is very
short-lived so if you teach something
after two hours it forgets
okay
so for example you can teach the worm
you can take an order that it likes and
pair it with starvation and then it
would dislike the auto
and then there's a simple test you just
put it in a plate you put the auto in
one side and a controller or another
side and you see whether it's prefers
this other or not and it stops
preferring it okay
there is 30 years or more of research 40
Years of research on on this showing
that the worms forget after two hours
the reason I went to study C Elegance is
that I wanted to understand memory okay
because such a simple nervous system you
say maybe I have the potential to
actually understand how it works but
this is slightly disappointing because
they forget after two hours so what is
it exactly okay
my idea was and I tried to convince
students to do it for 10 years is to
take the worms teach them this
Association to dislike the odor that
they innately like and then just put the
worms in -80 and freeze them
freeze them completely thaw them and see
whether they still remember after their
thought the Han Solo expressed and I
didn't want to do it because of kryoc
reservation or something like this I
wanted to do it because as you know
better than me many theories about
memory say that you need electrical
activity to maintain the memory you need
to reverberate it in the brain during
dreams or replay of the thing or
whatever and even memories will
nevertheless be kept even though the
worms
were frozen in -80 it would mean
that it was kept in the absence of of
electricity because there's no
electricity in minus 80 degrees this was
the idea I asked many students no one
wanted to do it because of it's not so
easy and also a little crazy well and
when the pi the principal investigator
lab has a pet experiment no one wants to
do that experience
so I and then then I agreed to do a Dana
land shift I was very happy only later
to find out that she ignored me
completely and did a different
experiment
the experiment the data did in instead
is to just take the worms teach them the
association and place them on ice
she wanted to see how the kinetics of
memories were getting changed
in low temperature because maybe
whatever memory is
the breakdown of the memory is affected
by the temperature
a very simple idea different experiment
a different experiment yeah but I could
experiment very cool and what she found
is that when you place the worms on ice
after you teach them they just don't
forget if there even 10 times longer
than control worms at that point after
24 hours if no one wants to forget after
two hours after 24 hours the worms will
become sick so normally we do shorter
experiments okay but for two hours the
ones don't forget
this is cool but it was only the
beginning
because
the Boeing explanation is just what I
just said everything slows down in low
temperatures so the breakdown of memory
again we don't know what it is but
whatever it is happens slower in low
temperatures
but this is not the case it's not merely
the physical it's the response it's the
changing of the internal state of the
worms which affects the memory kinetics
how do we know this there's a beautiful
work over the last one years on cold
tolerance in C Elegance nematodes
if you take the worms and you place them
on ice
like she did but longer for 48 hours
they all die
however if you take the worms
acclimate them to lower temperatures for
a few hours
five hours is the minimum and then place
them on Ice they all survive they become
cold tolerant and people who study this
show that this involves changes in lipid
metabolism and many things
so Dana took the worms acclimated them
to slightly lower temperatures made them
cold resistant and then taught them the
association
and place them on ice and now they
forgot immediately
which means that when they change their
internal state to become tolerant they
no longer extend memories on that which
means it's not only the temperature
because the temperature is anyway low
now they don't remember we took this as
a starting point to understand what
which genes change when the worms are
becoming call tolerant on and off eyes
and we found genes that when you mutate
them the worms just remember longer
always even when they're off eyes
because these are the genes that
normally change when they are surprised
on the eyes
and these genes are expressed just in
one pair of neurons just two out of the
302 . notice he said 302 not 300. and we
can manipulate the activities of these
genes in these neurons
to extend memory
and then the punch line of everything
that happened is that we found out that
this this nylon where these genes
function this one pair of neuron is the
only known in Silicon which is sensitive
to lithium
and lithium is a drug that is being
given to bipolar disorder patients for
decades although it's not entirely clear
how it works it's very very interesting
it is also interesting there's an
episode of course in your podcast about
this you know more about this than me a
lot but it's also interesting because
it's just an atom created with a big
bank yet it works on our brains in such
a fundamental way and we wanted to see
whether it works on also on the world
because this neuron was tied to this
memo extension phenotype that we found
so Dana grew the worms on lithium remove
them from lithium
called them the association and found
out that they learned a lot they
remember a lot longer than control ones
not only that if you first make the
worms called tolerant
and then lithium doesn't work on them so
lithium switches this forgetfulness
mechanism on and off amazing and it's it
all and it's all connected to cold
tolerance
amazing and amazing for a number of
reasons and so at risk of being
long-winded in my response I just wanted
to highlight something
um that I think will be of relevance to
most people which is when uh at some
point we did a few episodes on memory
um and I highlighted a review that was
written by the great James McGaw one of
the great mammalian memory researchers
who's worked a lot on humans and mice
and I was
um shocked uh pun intended and uh amused
to learn that in medieval times if
people wanted children to remember
lessons they could be religious lessons
or School Doctrine or whatever it was
mathematics whether they would take
children teach them and then throw them
into cold water to introduce a memory
instilling event and we now know that
the memory instilling event is the
release of adrenaline in the body which
makes perfect sense if you think about
traumatic events but it also this whole
General mechanism also applies to the
learning of other types of information
and so if I understand correctly about
the role of lithium and the role of cold
in the experiments that you just
described there's some General State
switch some internal State switch that
says what happened in the minutes or
hours preceding this was important it
acts as sort of like a highlighter pen
in the book of experiences
um and I'm
absolutely curious to know whether or
not this is an RNA dependent mechanism
in some way so is this literally like
the highlighter in the Ikea instruction
book this we don't know this we don't
know and as I said this is not even a
finished work it's not peer-reviewed
it's just the state that I told you
about but uh but it's very exciting for
for me to to go into this new feeling
you know once it's out I'll be happy to
to talk more about it uh and think about
the implications and the connections to
other things and more about the
mechanisms yeah well thank you for uh
sharing with us despite the fact that
it's not finished with
um people now know that it's also not
finished and I love a good Cliffhanger
so we we await the folk the full
conclusion and interpretation of these
results
today you've taken us on an amazing
journey through the genome RNA uh short
interfering rnas um a ton of history of
Prior experiments some of which ended
tragically many of which unfortunately
did not they were true triumphs and um
in particular the work in your
laboratory which is just incredible and
also this introduction of model
organisms so and I only mentioned a
short handful of the things that you've
taught us about today so first I want to
extend thanks for the incredible
teaching I also want to say thank you
for something equally important which is
uh that absolutely came through but is
what initially
um brought me to explore you and your
work more although I had certainly heard
of you which is that your spirit and
kind of approach to biology
um is an is an extremely unique and
intoxicating one it's uh it's even I
venture to call it seductive it's you
know there's a I do believe that whether
or not it's music or poetry or science
or or mathematics that the spirit behind
something dictates the amount of
intelligence and and precision with
which that thing is is carried out and
um it absolutely comes through so if I'm
making you feel on the spot about this
and I've succeeded thank you thank you
very much but I know that the listeners
can can feel it it's it's a felt thing
so thank you there there are many
scientists out there fewer with this
phenotype and even fewer that
um you know I think they can communicate
with such uh articulate Precision so
thank you so much thank you it's been a
real pleasure pleasure was all mine
thanks a lot great well we'll do it
again and we'll learn about all the
incredible things you're doing trying to
transform science as it were at the
level of publishing at the level of
social media because there's a whole
other discussion there meanwhile we will
of course Point people in the direction
of you and um to learn more about your
work and um I look forward to hearing
the conclusion of Dana's studies
thanks a lot it's been a real pleasure
thank you for joining me today for my
discussion with Dr ODed rakhavi about
genetics inheritance the epigenome and
transgenerational passage of traits if
you're learning from and are enjoying
the podcast please subscribe to our
YouTube channel that's a terrific zero
cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a
five-star review if you have questions
for us or comments or suggestions about
topics you'd like us to cover or guess
you'd like me to include on the huberman
Lab podcast please put those in the
comments section on YouTube I do read
all the comments in addition please
check out the sponsors mentioned the
beginning and throughout today's episode
that's the best way to support this
podcast not so much on today's episode
but on many previous episodes of The
huberman Lab podcast we discuss
supplements while supplements aren't
necessary for everybody many people
derive tremendous benefit from them for
things like improving sleep improving
focus and for hormone support the
huberman Lab podcast is proud to partner
with momentous supplements we've done
that for several reasons first of all
momentous supplements are the very
highest quality also they tend to focus
on single ingredient formulations which
makes it very straightforward to build
the most cost effective and biologically
effective supplement regimen for you
we've also partnered with momentous
because we realize that many listeners
of this podcast reside outside of the
United States and fortunately momentous
ships internationally if you'd like to
learn more about the supplements
discussed on the huberman Lab podcast
you can go to live momentous spelled ous
so that's livemomentis.com huberman if
you're not already following us on
social media please feel free to do so
we are huberman lab on Instagram Twitter
Facebook and Linkedin and at all those
places I cover information some of which
overlaps with the content of the uberman
Lab podcast but much of which is
distinct from content on the huberman
Lab podcast so again it's huberman lab
on all social media channels the
huberman Lab podcast also has a
so-called neural network newsletter this
is a zero cost monthly newsletter that
consists of podcast summaries and
so-called tool kits and those tool kits
range from things like a toolkit for
sleep for Focus for controlling dopamine
deliberate cold exposure for increasing
focus and much much more if you want to
sign up for that newsletter you can go
to hubermanlab.com go to the menu scroll
down to newsletter you simply provide
your email and I assure you we do not
share your email with anybody and again
it's a completely zero cost newsletter
find it at hubermanlab.com thank you
once again for joining me for today's
discussion with Dr ODed rachavi and last
but certainly not least thank you for
your interest in science
[Music]